want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some awesome
motivation
from brendan burchard
ambition ambition but too many of us
back away from it because it got made
bad
right i was scared to have ambition
because you know what if you have
ambition too big for your britches
people start insulting you who do you
think you are
oh you think you can do that you don't
even have any skill at that
you think you can do that you haven't
had their training you don't have the
degree
you don't have the experience you don't
have the background you don't have the
social following
you don't have the environment you don't
have the money you don't have the bank
account you don't have the credit you
don't handle that
and people start puking on you when you
share your big dream with them
you're like hey look no listen i'm
trying to go up here this is this is
where i want to be
right here i got this dream it's huge i
got this ambition
this dream this hunger for more and
immediately
people seek to see whether or not you
are qualified
and they judge you based on your past of
qualification
versus your present of how you show up
i don't judge anybody on their path
actually let me see how you show up
right now
because everybody in this room how many
of you all screwed up a bunch in your
life
i mean oh man i'm such a screw-up it's
so great
we're all screw-ups in some ways or
another but how are you showing up
now is the question how hard are you
willing to work now
what's the discipline you're willing to
put in now yes gain that knowledge skill
and ability
but your ambition everything i do
everything you see me do at a public
level
i had the ambition for a mission but i
didn't have the skills to do any of this
never thought i was crazy i'm going to
leave a safe job
go out of grad school i got a safe
corporate job i would say a safe
corporate job but it was a good job
and i liked it and it was a good job and
it had a clear
a career sort of a very clear path to
rising
and i just didn't i had something else i
wanted to do
so i quit that job and everyone else
said i was crazy i wanted to go
write books i had never written books
before
i didn't know how to do that and then i
decided my first major book
was going to be a work of fiction a book
called life's golden ticket
and i'd never written a parable before
but i remember reading the alchemist and
being so inspired by paulo cuello's
yakuza y'all read that book
i hope you all read that it's now the
seventh most read book in the history of
the world
it's unbelievable right so i and then
the longest-running book on the new york
times in history is now the alchemist
and i remember reading that book and i
thought i related with the storytelling
in it and i wanted to write life school
and take it but not tell my story my
accident but rather tell the story of
the character going through change
and i got this blessed meeting with a
big famous author in san francisco
and i was so excited i mean because i've
been wanting to write so i went and had
this big meeting with this big fancy
uh you know author i wore a suit and i
got all dressed up and i was so nervous
and i sat and i talked with this person
and he's hearing me describe
very passionately why i want to write
this book and what my life's message is
about second chances
because life school and ticket is really
a story about second chances
and so i want to tell a story about
second chances and i was so excited and
i'm telling him
he goes so wait this is your life's
message i go yeah and he says you're
really passionate i go yeah and he goes
but you've never written fiction i go
no and he goes brandon i'll never forget
it goes brendan
do not risk your life's message
on your freshman effort at fiction
fiction's hard i i admire that you want
to write this book and that's your dream
and that's your ambition
that's your goal but you don't know how
to do that ambition's really hard people
go to writer's conferences for their
lives
they get creative writing degrees they
like he said everyone in this building i
mean we spent
decades trying to figure out how to do
fiction and you're just going to come
and write this fiction book
i don't think that's a good idea i think
you need to write a non-fiction book
and what happens is we have this big
aspiration
but because we don't know the how
sometimes
someone tells us you don't know how so
what do you do
if you don't know the how yeah you
minimize it
you drop it back down to here maybe you
drop it back down to here
maybe it's like here
it started up there but you didn't know
the how and you let other people
drop that down so i listened to the guy
i said okay i
i guess you're right it's true it sounds
logical to me i don't know what the hell
i'm doing
so maybe i shouldn't risk my life's
effort so then i spent two and a half
years
struggling in san francisco trying to
write
life's golden ticket as a non-fiction
book and it just it was like pulling
teeth
i couldn't get it you know it wasn't
working and then it was so frustrating
and i was like i need to figure this out
because it was the time i was about to
leave my job and everything and i was
putting everything at risk i said okay
the timing all turned out
went back to my childhood home where i
grew up tiny little
home tiny little bedroom riding on my
mom's sewing room table
at the time to complete the book and in
18 days
i said you know what i got to stop
trying to write the book they told me to
write
and write this book that i feel like i
should write and i started all over from
scratch
complete scratch 18 days all i did i got
up
my mom made an amazing big breakfast i'd
eat a big old breakfast
and i'd write and i'd write in a right
but dad would come home from work we'd
go play racquetball
i'd come home i'd write and i write in
the right until it was so dark and my
eyes
hurt it was so late and i'd get up from
my desk and i'd
walk around my childhood neighborhood
where i grew up and
my school and my elementary school and
the playgrounds we'd play in
and then i'd go back go to bed i'd get
up and i did the same thing for 18 days
that's it 18 days and at the end of 18
days
life's golden ticket was done submitted
to thank you thank you it was 18 magical
days
if you've ever read the book there's a
huge surprise at the end i didn't even
know that was coming
i did not see that come i mean sure so
however shocked you felt imagine me i
was writing the book
i was just typing along watching them
like oh damn
i remember i finished i'm watching the
movie i finished the book i'm like whoa
can that even happen and i literally got
up and i was walking around the little
desk and like
[Music]
that character did i do this i gotta and
i had to go for a walk just to think
about if the book could even end because
i didn't know the book was about to end
it just ended with that scene and i was
like oh my gosh
it was a huge surprise to me and i knew
it was magic i knew his magic
we put it out there 21 publishers turned
it down
21. my agent still jokes to this day he
only told me about 19 of them turning it
down because he didn't think i could
take the other few more
that came in turn it down turn it down
turn it down finally boom harpercollins
gets it
an editor who happened to edit and
publish another book called
the alchemist
fell in love with life's golden ticket
and gave it a shot
we put it out there and i got this dream
to be this big author i'm gonna go
we launched life school and ticket i
have no idea
none what i'm doing put the book out
there we get a bunch of quick early hits
because i had all these promotional
partners
uh in these nonprofits we were donating
money to who supported the book
got out there boom charts on amazon
really great next week
no one's buying it totally i mean this
ambition just keeps getting stumped down
no one likes your book
big author says it's stupid they're all
turning it down and it doesn't sell
think about what that can do to your
psychology think about me now
saying i'm a writer after the book
doesn't do well after everyone turns it
down after they say don't do it
think about that how where that could
have directed me
but your ambition is your own and your
ambition
has to be free from all of that negative
if that's a real ambition
you got to own that ambition
psychologically
i was a writer i said i was a writer i
said i was a writer on days i didn't
write
i said i was a writer on the days they
all turned me down i said i was a writer
when that guy who was a big name fancy
writer who'd been on all the big shows
including oprah
told me i was kind of crazy and i walked
out of his office all dejected
i was still a writer sometimes what
really gives us the greatest amount of
motivation is when we got the guts
to actually allow ourselves to tie some
of our identity to what we're doing
and we're told not to do that because it
can bring discouragement
and heartache but the counterintuitive
things is
high performers to a t the top 15
percent
who i interviewed they said oh no
they were comfortable tying up their
identity and what they were doing
they were comfortable it didn't mean it
always turned out great it didn't mean
they always felt great but they were
comfortable owning it
right they were comfortable owning what
they were doing
they owned that and because they owned
it the motivation was there
because you know when the motivation
isn't there is when your ambitions are
half-assed when you kind of want it you
kind of don't
and that's why you kind of work for it
sometimes and sometimes you kind of
don't
because psychologically you haven't
allowed yourself to own the ambition
to feel it inside and say that's part of
me i'm going to make that happen
come hell or high water i didn't care
the first book i said maybe the next
book neither the next book maybe the
next book
didn't matter to me i was going to keep
on that ambition because it was
important to me
you've got ambitions important to you
and your family and the people you're
serving
and it doesn't matter what i say or the
person you're left or right says if you
own that ambition
you pursue it and you pursue it with
full heart
and will you pursue it with more hearts
that ambition
that keeps sparking over and over and
over you have to rev yourself up
because it is you i'm often asked
brendan how can i believe
in myself more you know sometimes we get
knocked down
sometimes we just struggle for days or
weeks or months or or decades
you know and we have that like i just
lost faith in myself somewhere
i was so confident in my in my teens or
or my 20s or my 30s or whenever
and now i lost my mojo man i just don't
i don't have the confidence in the in
the
vibe and the pop and i just i lost faith
in myself what can i do
and i don't have a pat easy answer for
that but i got five
ideas here that might just help you i'm
outside here
at my writer's villa in oregon and i
thought you know what why don't we just
talk about this a tough topic but let's
take it on
so forgive the sounds of nature if we
got them forget the sounds of anything
going by but let's rock and roll
number one way to start to believe in
yourself is
momentum now i know
off the bat if you really hate yourself
right now you're like thanks brendan i
got no momentum that's why i hate myself
so hold on i'll get to the mindset stuff
i'll get to the emotional stuff
but sometimes believing in yourself is
just tactically
winning a little bit each day
you know just a little bit of a win can
give you that dopamine that says oh
good job reward i feel better it can be
a very simple neurological payoff
of just achieving a couple small goals
and as you've
heard me say anytime you're dealing with
difficulty it can be just simple things
but it's got a momentum so whatever
you're doing in your life if you got a
job
think about what small things can i do
tomorrow
to move ahead if you're dealing with a
difficulty in a relationship
what would be a simple win a simple
moment of appreciation
just something they could say or you
could say to put some more pop and
energy back
into that relationship just one smile
one kiss one good date
can change the game for you also
if it's just something simple you can do
in your own your own health look
sometimes going to the gym and leaving
you feel a little
better you know just a little bit of
movement
has been proven to change people's
states of
minds and their emotions too so just get
in the gym
or get a little bit of small goal
setting get a little bit of momentum
forward in
any area of your life that's at least
the beginning
and then do it again the next day
don't just go and crush it tomorrow and
then be a jerk and
do nothing and watch seven seasons of
netflix
on the next day momentum is daily
little things every single day adds up
to greatness
second big piece and this is more of the
emotional side integration
my friend integration people who don't
believe in themselves
it's often it's not that there hasn't
been evidence that they shouldn't
believe in themselves they've had some
wins they've had some goals that
came true they they made the magic
happen but they never
integrated the win they never
had a good thing happen and they sat
there at the end of the night
thinking about that good thing that
happened and and allowing it
to come into their heart allowing
whatever they did
to to give themselves credit for it
permission to feel good about it to say
you know what i i did this today it went
well today
that worked today and to integrate that
win
integrate that success integrate that
moment into their heart
into their identity as a human being
what happens is most of us we knock off
the checklist and did it did it did it
did it did it did it
and five years later after all these did
it did it did it made it happen maybe it
happened crushed the question question
question five years later we feel the
same
about ourselves the same level of
confidence the same level of belief in
ourselves
because we didn't allow those things to
enter
our psyche enter our spirit as strength
we didn't we took we had momentum
externally but we didn't have any
momentum
internally building our character and
our strength we never achieved
that sense of pride or ownership of what
we did
we didn't own it that we did it so we
never got stronger
that means you need an integration
practice
at the end of the day just sit down at
the end of the day and go what worked
today
what did i do today what little thing
should i allow myself a little bit of
credit for
what did i say that was nice or kind
what did i send
away that i got done what did i finish
what goal did i move a little closer to
and just at the end of the day to allow
that to come in
this isn't about just pepping ourselves
up and saying i'm awesome i'm awesome
i'm awesome with no evidence i'm saying
you know you got some momentum
integrate that now own that you did the
work today
you fought the good fight you finished
the day you're still
alive you know what you need to go do
tomorrow
integrate that success give yourself
that credit you'll develop that strength
of spirit that's so important
if you don't believe in yourself after
all that hey bub
get some feedback you know most people
fear this when you don't believe in
yourself you don't want any feedback
because they might say you're stupid or
you suck or you're ugly and you know if
they do that
you're getting feedback from the wrong
people sometimes
it's necessary to get feedback from the
people that we love
feedback from people we know like and
trust and just say hey
can i ask you a question what am i doing
that you're seeing that
seems right because right now i don't
feel like i'm doing anything right and
they'll say what are you talking about
no you're smart you're good you've been
doing this sometimes people can give us
feedback and help us see that we
are doing better than we think because
maybe you're perfectionist
or maybe you grew up with somebody who
pushed so hard on you
you never integrated any successes and
sometimes you need somebody pushing hard
at you saying
good job kid you're doing all right
i'm proud of you i see that you're
working hard here
i see that you're trying so sometimes
it's about getting around a new social
circle of people who are strivers who
are also struggling who are fighting
hard who can give you that feedback and
say
good job keep at it and if you do get
negative feedback over and over and over
assess is it real do you need to change
and shift and get better
and if you do don't hate that don't get
mad at that take that as a challenge
instead of taking things as a insult and
crying
over people's comments go huh you know
what that's kind of
got some basis in reality i'm going to
take that as a challenge
i'm going to develop myself not to prove
them wrong
but to get better allow yourself that
allow that feeling to come from the
feedback next up i love this one it's so
simple
it's just priming the emotions that we
want to experience
in our life what does that mean it means
doing something in
advance so we can feel it and here's
what i mean by that
in the morning every single day see i
want to be i want to be motivated
and driven i want to feel grateful for
life
i want to have a sense of passion about
the day but you know what some days i
wake up and i feel like crap
so what am i gonna do go through the day
and just allow my impulsive feelings
to tell me to feel like crap all day and
lose multiple days no
i'm gonna say okay i recognize i feel
like crap why
i didn't sleep well or or why i got this
bad attitude right now
i'm gonna change it in the morning i do
an affirmation
practice and visualization practice
where what i do
is i pick up something every single
morning i do this i grab
a little just a couple paragraphs maybe
i read from
uh my bible maybe i read from one of my
books or another book it's a passage
i have a bunch of passages in my notes
section my phone too if i'm on the road
and i'll just read it out loud
pretending that i'm like
in my most passionate happy place in my
life so i'll be
reading out loud from franklin delano
roosevelt i'll be reading out loud some
martin luther king i'll be reading out
loud some napoleon hill
or reading out loud some earl
nightingale as loud as i can
and that voice activates a
power which activates an emotion which
activates my day
so you just got a prime emotion or
sometimes i'll be in the shower and i'll
say
what can i do today or what i'm going to
do today
that would bring a laugh what can i
do today that i'm excited for and i'll
just get my
energy up like don't wait to have good
energy in life remember
as i always say the power plant doesn't
have energy it generates it
you don't have happiness you generate it
so
choose to prime the emotions you want to
experience life cultivate it
summon your energy versus hoping a good
one lands on you
and you'll start to feel better about
yourself and about life and the last big
one you knew i was going to go there
love you know
you already know the thing about love
yourself and maybe in some
ways you've never allowed that you've
never noticed the beautiful things
you've done in
your life so you've never allowed
yourself to love
yourself but at some point you've got to
recognize that there's a love that's
beyond you
and beyond me and beyond your actions
and that love is whatever bought us
here alive today some would say it's
god's will and god's love some people
it's
the randomness of the universe some
people it's nature some people it's
whatever but there is something way
beyond us
and there's a way to access that and a
way to honor that
and the way to honor that is to
recognize that you are unique about of
seven billion people no one is like
you specifically and
at least take that as a moment saying
okay
i'm meant to live my uniqueness i'm out
i'm supposed to love the things that
make me odd and weird
i'm supposed to love the things that
make me strong i'm supposed to
i was made this way so let me honor
what's good about that
and what's not good about that let me
work on that let me set a schedule to
get better at that
so that i can not only honor what i've
been given but i can give something back
to by getting
better and that aspect
of doing that that brings in so much joy
and so much strength in our life is love
loving ourselves loving the process and
of course
the greatest way to believe in ourselves
is to love
other people that they become so
grateful for us
that they give us some of that feedback
that they that there's so much
appreciation and love and joy in the
moment
with others that you can't help but just
feel that vibe that there's an emotional
contagion
when other people around you are feeling
loved and cared for and
excited about life it's hard not to rub
off on you a little bit and you start to
say you know what
life isn't so bad and you know what i
deserve to feel good here right now too
and you know what you start getting some
momentums some wins you
integrate those wins you get some
feedback to get better and all of a
sudden you start to believe in yourself
again
all of a sudden you start to live the
charge
what is high performance i know you guys
see me quoted all the time as high
performance
coach brandon burchard but what the heck
does that mean
well for me it means i coach people to
reach their highest levels of
performance and
potential in everything that they're
doing but what is high performance and
and who is a high performer and and how
do you get there
well i've spent 19 years researching and
working and coaching people
through this topic because i just feel
like isn't that what we all want
you know we all want to become our best
at whatever we're doing and we don't
become our best
over a short period of time you know
we're not i don't think many people are
looking for peak performance you know
teach me to be good
real good and and then of course what's
at the bottom or the next part of every
peak
a valley a drop it's like we want
heightened and sustained
performance and potential in our life we
want it to be heightened
we want to sustain it that's what we
call high performance
as a sort of textbook definition we
could say it means in our personal lives
it means succeeding and excelling over
the long term above standard norms
that means we do better than we usually
would
for a long period of time we maintain
our potential we maintain our success we
maintain
the energy the vibe the flow the zone
whatever you call it
right a lot of athletes would say you
know i had a season
where i was really in the zone what they
meant was
they hit high performance that season
you know that was a season when they
were excelling beyond what they normally
did and they maintained it and those
times in our lives are
amazing right i mean have you ever had a
time at work when you really hit your
stride
where you really hit high performance it
seems like you're being more productive
than you usually were
more productive than even your teammates
or maybe even your supervisor were you
were just like
you're like in the flow you're on for a
period of time
i don't mean just a day or a week i mean
you are really on it
for a couple of months or maybe even a
year or two
that's when you hit high performance my
quest has been to figure out
what happened in that year or two for
you or what happened in that season for
the athlete so they can grasp it again
so they can get it back
my whole career is ultimately about
figuring that out i mean
if you read all my books it's always
trying to figure out how do we
draw from ourselves the greatest amount
of
energy engagement enthusiasm
we can so we can experience what we call
the charged life
and i feel like if we experience the
charge life enough
that's when we hit high performance in
all areas
of our life that's when we feel like you
know it's just our relationships are
vibing and going really well
our career is vibing and going really
well our hobbies our passions
now it would be a little bit crazy to
think all those things could always be
perfect and
that's not what i'm after at all i'm not
after perfection i'm after
excellence i'm after how can we
all achieve our best but keep at that
level
where instead of life where it's ups and
downs and ups and downs and ups and
downs for so many people
that's not we're after when an olympic
athlete hires me
or a fortune 50 ceo hires me the reason
they do it
is because they know i'm going to get
them up here i'm gonna keep them up
there
because they can't afford in the
marketplace to have ups and downs
their sponsors don't like when they have
lots of wins and losses
they they hit peak performance in a game
but the next game they fall back down
it's like no how do we keep them up
there well here's what i found
there's basically five qualities of
high performance it's that people who
are high performing in any area
they got these five things going on for
them and if we can just get you to that
point where we maintain those
five things then we could call you a
high performer no matter what you're
doing
and so what's the first one the first
quality of high performance or a high
performer
is clarity they've got just an
uncommon amount of clarity about who
they are
what they're seeking to do or achieve or
experience
they've got a heightened quality about
what their interactions should be with
other people
it's just they're very very very
focused again they're clear about who
they are
about what they're after how they should
be interacting with other people what
experiences they're i mean they just
they're in the zone because they know
their goal
they're in the zone because they know
what they're about they know their
strengths
they know what the game is and all that
clarity in their life
allows them to make better decisions to
focus on what's important
to get rid of distractions to be who
they truly are
to be intentional all that comes from
clarity
and without clarity we just there's no
way we could ever reach
high performance in our lives the second
thing that we know
for sure is there's heightened and
sustained levels of energy
high performers have more energy a high
performing athlete has more energy than
one who's dogging it
we know that there's a physical vitality
a mental stamina two
that goes along with their days the
energy it's just
it's like it's palpable you can feel it
around them
and of course it's not luck they're
generating that energy
they're conditioning that energy in
their body
by their training regimen they're
conditioning the energy
in their mental stamina by having the
clarity of what to focus on what not to
focus on
and getting very disciplined about where
they give their
time energy effort attention so
they're not pulled in a million
different places
because you know how it is if you're
pulled in a million different places or
you're multitasking dozens and dozens of
things
you're kind of your energy is dissipated
theirs is extraordinarily
focused and powered up with reserves
the third thing that we see is a
heightened level of courage
that they're more likely to speak up for
themselves
to speak up for their ideas to know what
they stand for
to take bold action and risks than other
people
that's what high performers do they're
they're more willing to speak up for
themselves
take action and take risks than other
people
and that's why they tend to get ahead a
little bit better than other people
because so many other people are are
paralyzed with you know analysis
paralysis they're
scared about what to do they're
unwilling to take that risk that might
just give them that extra edge
and so high performers are very focused
on being courageous
they in fact tend to sort of
focus on the word courage in their work
they know that it takes a high degree of
courage to
put their ideas out there to express
who they truly are with the world to say
no to things that aren't
on their path or of their passion to
stick to their purpose
even when the whole world is judging
them or pushing them
they stay the course they have the
courage
to stay the course and because they do
that
they outperform everybody else who gave
up or quit
when they got judged or when it was too
hard or who were too scared to take the
action
so we have to look at people's courage
to see how they're doing in their life
the next thing we know the fourth
element of high performance is
productivity high performers just
produce more
if you look at a high performing athlete
they're putting in more hours
on the field if you look at a high
performing executive
they're more efficient and effective
with their time
than their counterparts it's just it
seems in the same amount of time
they get more done or they get into the
experience deeper or they're more
efficient and effective at it
and because they are obviously they're
able to get ahead faster than other
people
but we have to look at that in our own
lives you know how productive
have you been in this last couple weeks
be honest about it because it's going to
dictate whether or not you're going to
ever reach your full potential
isn't it true productivity has so much
to do with our full potential
you look at even an artist a lot of
artists are
judged based on how prolific they were
were they productive in their careers
did they put out one painting or were
they like monet
where did they put out one music you
know one musical arrangement
or were they a beethoven were they
thinking of one formula or were they
solving all formulas like einstein
there's something about a high performer
in any area
that they just get more done partially
because they stay at it
partially because of clarity energy and
courage
so honestly evaluating ourselves in that
area is vital
a lot of the work i do with senior
executives comes back down to
reclaiming their life reclaiming their
day if you read the motivation manifesto
you saw
declaration number two is reclaim your
agenda
get your life's agenda back get your
life back on track
take back control discover what you
truly want and start moving towards that
with greater
boldness effectiveness and efficiency
and life changes
last one high performers have a greater
level of
influence they have greater people
skills
you know they're just kind of good with
other people because they give
other people time attention
respect honor and by caring about other
people deeply
they tend to get what they want too
because other people see them as
compassionate
and kind so they reciprocate and
because they have high levels of ability
to to give and to take and to be with
other people
in influential ways to lead other people
to be a good role model for other people
other people admire and respect them so
they help them
they join their team they cheer them on
they support them they invest in them
because frankly they tend to be
exceptionally
caring good contributing people
now is it possible for all of us to
become high performers
the answer is yes are high performers
born or made
they're conditioned it's they're created
by habit
in each of these areas even if they
didn't know it
each of these areas i've worked with a
lot of people like i mentioned
even major celebrities or music stars
they might not have ever
even thought consciously about clarity
energy
courage productivity and influence but
you look at their lives
and those elements are there and they're
sharpened
and they're honed they're sharp in their
home because they've focused on
their life they're mastering their mind
their emotions
their schedule they focus on the
discipline of creating real
knowledge skills talent abilities and
they've done it longer than anyone else
and so those areas
they got sharpened even if just by luck
and
habit my job is to ask questions
of our clients to help them find greater
levels of power in each of those areas
that's what makes me a high performance
coach is i know how to work with
people's psychology
their physiology their productivity
their people skills
to heighten those five levels of clarity
energy
courage productivity and influence i
hope that this has helped you to kind of
explain
what the heck it is i do what the heck
it is so many certified high performance
coaches
do out there in the world and i hope
that someday you consider
yourself a high performer or you make it
a life's goal to help people
reach higher performance you can check
out my websites or visit us at high
performance academy
at some point in your life and we'll
talk about it there and that's where
people get certified and learn
about how to become a high performance
coach but i just hope this answers your
question a lot of people ask me all the
time what the heck do you do brandon
well that's what i do i hope that by
just talking about this you evaluated
your life a little bit
more closely in those five areas of high
performance
get good at those five areas and tell
you what you'll start to experience what
we call
the charge life when you feel like crap
do not pretend that that is a mystery
that feeling that you have when you're
down you're sad you're in a funk you're
bored
you just don't like the negative
emotions you might be feeling
stop pretending that that feeling just
took over your body and oh my gosh i
don't know what to do with it
because what i've learned is usually
when you feel like crap
that's coming from three specific places
number one when you feel like crap it's
often just coming straight up from
fatigue you didn't sleep well you didn't
eat well you didn't manage your physical
body so it's now it's catching up with
you
right you had too much wine two days ago
and now it caught up with you 48 hours
and you didn't even realize it like
your body is depleted you feel like crap
when you need
rest when you need recovery and you have
to listen to that y'all
you got to do a better job of listening
to that when your body is saying hey man
we need a break here we need a break
from the caffeine or the alcohol
or the lack of sleep the first thing is
to start taking better care of your
physical body
the more you take good care of your
physical body the less like it is you're
gonna be
like crap over and over and over and
over again now there's emotional things
and there's the ways you manage your
mind we'll talk about those but often
when you feel like crap
it's just kind of a hangover effect if
not alcohol
a hangover fact of poor sleep a hangover
effect of
not eating well it's just like you're
really tired and lethargic
by the way you've managed your body and
i asked this question
in like high performance habits my last
book and the motivation manifesto i said
how is it that very few of us would go
to the neighbor's house
and you know just break through the
windows throw garbage in that house
vandalize that house and yet so many of
us on a daily basis
vandalize the temple that we have been
given by our creator
we vandalize our own physical body
you know we don't take care of ourselves
and then we end up feeling like crap and
we're surprised by it
i don't want you to ever be surprised
again i mean i think that's one
sort of mark of real maturity or
consciousness
is that you learn to anticipate how
you're going to feel later on based on
your actions today
is that you learn to dig deep and
understand like
why do i feel the way that i feel right
now and when we are
more able to anticipate how we're going
to feel based on our current actions
and when we do feel a certain emotion or
feeling that we don't like
we have the wherewithal to kind of take
a step back but why am i feeling this
meaning we're more conscious of the
feeling and we explore it more do that
over and over and over and over again
you have less bad days
not to say the world isn't going to
throw something at you because i said
there's three reasons i tend to feel
like crap
number one is just straight up fatigue
number two
is reaction every time i feel in a funk
or i feel in a bad
mood or i feel some negative positive
range i go say what am i reacting to
right now
maybe somebody was rude to me this
morning maybe somebody popped in and
gave a poor comment
maybe uh i'm reacting to an email i got
maybe i'm reacting to
a negative thought i had this morning
maybe i had i'm reacting still to that
guy who cut me off
in traffic this morning and i'm still
freaking out about it but usually
feeling like crap
is actually coming from a reaction so
ask what am i reacting to
because usually when you feel that crap
if you're not sure of why
you're reacting to something but you're
just reacting to it unconsciously you're
not aware of it
you're not in tune with what's really
happening and so
this this funk is on you but secretly
in the back of your mind something
happened that really upset you
and you're still tracking on that so i
always look for
am i reacting to something that just
happened to me am i reacting to
something that was triggered for me am i
reacting to something because someone
said something am i reacting to
something because i'm embarrassed
am i reacting because i did this i
shouldn't have done it am i reacting
because i feel behind
right sometimes overwhelm creates this
reaction right
there's all this stuff you react to it
and what do you react to it with
stress you react to it by like getting
tense
you react to all these things on your
plate with anger why does this have to
happen to me
why did i over commit myself and we get
mad at ourselves
and that's the stuff of what i'm talking
about reaction when i'm in a funk i
almost
always know i'm reacting to something
what am i reacting to
so sit down and i'll journal i'll sit
down and i'll think about
what am i reacting to in such a way that
i feel this way
what am i reacting to in such a way that
i'm feeling this way feeling this
negative feeling or feeling this boredom
or feeling this funk
i think it's really important right
reaction often comes from sadness
right something could have happened two
three days ago but you've been so busy
it's just now processing in the back of
your mind
i mean have you guys ever had that
before where like literally think about
it
like something negative or sad happened
three days ago you didn't feel it then
because you're busy and then you have a
moment to breathe or you go on a workout
and you're coming back you're like oh my
gosh why do i feel like crap
and you realize you're just reacting
something that happened three four days
ago
so be aware of your reactions so i said
there's three things number one
that makes me feel like crap sometimes
it's fatigue it's the way i'm caring for
my physical body
number two it's reaction number three
rumination rumination what does that
mean
it means you get on a topic in your
brain and you keep
spinning it over and over and over again
like playing a broken
tape you know you're just playing it
over and over and over again what do we
do
well we we get upset about something and
you just can't get off it
you just keep thinking of it over and
over and over and over again so you're
ruminating usually on a negative
circumstance negative result
negative emotion negative feeling
negative interaction
and you are running on that thing over
and over and over again
and so it's like what happens for a lot
of people as an example
is maybe some days you feel doubt you
feel upset about something you're unsure
if you can handle it
and you let doubt stop you when all
doubt is
is a signal doubt is just a signal
to learn more to skill up to ask
questions to get ready
to acknowledge you could improve in this
area to acknowledge it maybe you need
some help in this area
and what happens though is when you get
doubtful many of us get on a
merry-go-round of doubt
right we think of why we're doubtful i'm
insufficient i'm not good i'm not worthy
i'm stupid i'm not as good as them
and we start spinning that like a
merry-go-round in our head and all of a
sudden we just spin the doubt so many
times it turns into fear
and then turns into self-disgust and
then we gotta throw up you know we feel
terrible
so i'm here to urge you be thoughtful
about what you are ruminating on
if you feel like crap i promise one of
these three reasons usually going on for
you
you're tired that's fatigue you're
reacting to something you might not be
aware you're reacting to
and number three you're ruminating
you're thinking about something
consciously
over and over and over and over again
and you need to interrupt that pattern
so how do you do that
well here's how i get out of feeling
like crap i mean the first thing that i
do
is i get up and i move i change my
location
and i change my movement and my breath
so what i do i literally if i'm sitting
here working for you guys you can see i
have my podcast mic today
if uh filming for the brandon show and
if i feel like crap
i mean i get up you can't see here let
me grab this camera but
you guys see out there i'm just this is
instagram only
uh you guys see that that's the ocean
so that's how close the ocean is to
where i'm at right now so what do i do
i hop up if i feel like crap i'm like
i'm gonna get up
i'm gonna go outside i'm gonna take a
walk but for me specifically
i go out i jump in that ocean i swim a
bunch
i mean maybe even literally two three
four five minutes swim
come back in take a cool shower and i
get my brain back on track what i had to
do is just change my location
and change my physical movement like
move like if you've ever been up some of
you guys have been to hpx or high
performance academy my event
and what we train you to do is just
stand up
bounce in place with your eyes closed
taking ten
deep breaths after you do that set your
intention where it's next
go it's just taking breath and moving
your body a little bit because
yeah you know what the easiest thing to
do is when you're in a funk sit on the
couch
and watch 40 hours of netflix but that
doesn't make you feel better
and even if it does take you feel better
it takes so long
and the other behaviors you're learning
to do there disengage from uncomfortable
feelings
munch on things all of a sudden you
actually
maybe you feel better but it's just time
away from your thoughts
but there's a faster way to recover than
that and that's just to move your body
that's first thing second thing that's
huge for me is
setting an intention okay i feel like
crap right now got it
get up move maybe jump in the ocean
maybe take a cool shower get some water
take ten
bouncing plates take ten deep breaths
and then say okay
what is my intention now for this next
hour notice i'm not trying to say i'm
i'm going to look at all my goals and go
achieve and change the world
no for the next hour what would be a win
in this next hour what would be
one two three four things i could do
just in the next hour
just in the next hour to feel better to
feel like i've got momentum again to
feel like i'm
progressing again to feel like i'm back
in charge i'm back into control
not this negative emotion not this
negative thing but i'm back in charge
what would that be for me
that's a thought that goes in my mind
third big idea
if i move my body if i set my intention
and i take small actions towards what i
need to and i still feel like i'm in a
funk
right away i'm going to put some
positive audio in my
ears right i'm gonna grab these little
earbuds and put them in
and i'm gonna listen to a positive
podcast positive music
a positive audio book i'm just gonna
like interrupt it literally
put this in turn it up and listen to
something positive or if i'm totally
geeking that day and i'm
just in a super funk i'm gonna go
straight to like uh
i don't know like go on youtube and i'm
gonna watch some like
you know 10 most emotional amazing you
know
american idol you know surprises or
something like that or america's got
talent i'll watch some talent thing
for like two three minutes that like
somebody who did something inspiring who
you didn't think was gonna be amazing
something goofy like that um but that's
gonna help me change
my feelings because i'm listening or
consuming something
that's really positive for me many of
you guys know i go to i go to my books
i'll read yes from my books or from a
shelf of books i have
of positivity self-development
self-improvement
self-help you know some spirituality
i'll just read some things that will
help kind of
reset me because you know what sometimes
reading or listening
helps put some new thoughts in your
brain to interrupt that rumination
fourth big thing i do is action
so i said what i'll do is i'll say
what's three things i can do
in this next hour to get myself back on
track but then i'll say okay good i got
someone meant to be i'm feeling better
by the end of the day what five things
can i do by the end of this day
to you know what pat myself on the back
to feel like i'm doing something good to
feel like i'm moving ahead
just taking action because sometimes
you want to feel like you know you're
back in command
and getting back in command that might
mean for you you do the laundry man
you know you you you make the bed you
straighten up the office
you know you answer those 10 critical
emails you already flagged
you know you do something that actually
moves your thoughts or
moves your dreams forward because your
your mind is just saying hey man
let's let's grab a little control here
let's have a phenomenal day let's get
you know
get yourselves turned around i know i
know you get what i'm saying
last big idea for you today is to share
that vulnerability with a good friend or
a partner or a spouse like if you're
just in a funk and you're like dang i've
been in a funk for like two three days
tell somebody that if you're in a funk
for
you know two three days and you're just
like i'm sad i've done what brendan said
i i've
i've moved i've walked around i've set
my intentions i'm getting some momentum
here
i did a you know i got some rest or i
meditated to recover my fatigue my body
i am eating better but i'm still just
not feeling it then what's happening is
you're usually just
off that path or that journey you've
lost a little
sense of presence and connection and
with life and sometimes the way to get
presence and connection back with life
is through somebody you care
about somebody you love connect with
them and say hey you know what i'm just
in a funk
you got an hour hey i'm going to funk do
you want to go for a walk hey i feel
like crap i want to go to the movies hey
i feel like crap let's go get something
to eat hey i feel like crap let's go
work out together let's take a long run
together
like go do something with somebody who
you like
i know that's so basic but the world is
full of sadness
but it's also full of sadness because we
have separated ourselves
so we can connect here but you and i
both know lots of people can connect on
social media but
they don't connect in real life with
people and they haven't
challenged themselves to to be
vulnerable open courageous
authentic real with other people
especially when the negative emotions
hit
but listen if you hold your negative
emotions to yourself your whole life
that's not going to be a life well lived
you've got to learn to connect with
people and say here's where i'm at
sucks i don't like it i've been trying
to get over it but i'm just
i'm struggling man and if you're not
ever sharing that
i'm telling you what it's going to
create a great obstacle for you
to grow so share connect with somebody
and just let them know i'm in a funk
don't know what to do want to hang out
that's all you have to say
in a funk don't know what to do want to
hang
that's all you have to do don't over
architect it just get around people
and if you get around great people and
more often more positive people
that will change the game for you i know
i'm going to see a lot of you guys
at hpx which is hbx live in san diego
if you don't have tickets for that make
sure you click the link in my bio
as uh the tickets i don't know if it's
closed out yet or it's pretty close to
sold out
over 2500 people will be up with us in
san diego
to spend three transformational days so
if you've been really stuck or you just
been like bummed out
and you want some more advanced training
and you want to get around 2 500
incredible people from
you know whatever is 40 countries around
the world join us at hpx you can get
tickets
by the link in my bio it's called hpx
live stands for the high performance
experience
it's coming up in san diego
so i hope this has served you guys i
really want you to realize
when you are in a funk you are still in
control
when you are in a funk you can take back
over the first thing is to do
ask am i just fatigued have i not been
taking care of myself let me take care
of my physical body more
maybe i can rest maybe i can sleep maybe
i can meditate maybe i can eat healthier
maybe you can't move
number two you had some reaction to
something that's been happening
and you're unaware of that so ask what
am i reacting to that's making me feel
like my defunct
and how can i flip that a little bit
number three what are you ruminating on
what are you negatively thinking on over
and over and over and over again
get off that merry-go-round of doubt or
rumination and get on a merry-go-round
of affirmation
on thinking about what you want of
thinking about your blessings
and thinking about what the
opportunities are for you and think
about how you can serve or care for
other people
simple tactical things you do five
simple things number one get up and move
like i said
i hop up from this chair i go out to
that ocean out there
and i just swim that's puerto rico by
the way i hope you all go to puerto rico
one day that's puerto rico
and so i get up i go swimming i change
my state i breathe i bounce in place
taking 10
deep breaths number two i set my
intention for the day
what do i want to do in this next hour
that when we move forward and what do i
want to
do by the end of the day to make myself
feel more positive number three
i pop in some positive audios great
podcasts great audio books
i watch some videos that motivates me
number four i figure out what some major
actions i can take towards my goals
and start doing that this day even if
just one or two big things
by the end of the day and number five
share
share talk with your spouse your friend
your partner somebody you care about and
just let them know where you
are at and i hope that will serve you i
believe that
fear gets way too much airplay you know
i think
so many people say well people don't
take action because they have too much
fear or
fear is holding people back and i think
this is so common in our language it's
almost
the point where it's almost comedic it's
ridiculous it's
like what are they fearful of what are
they so scared of you know we we live in
the modern world right now where
there's not all these impulsive fears
that are are driven by a physical
reality to be safe you know we're not
being
chased by animals that are trying to
kill us often right
so most of the fears that we actually
have are just
negative contemplative thoughts that
we're rerunning too often
and we're associating so much pain to
that now becomes convenient oh it's fear
as if some fear is some big unknowable
scary awful thing
well mostly it's not most fear is just
bad
management of our own mental faculties
it's not an impulsive
physical thing generating in our brain
telling us to
you know fight fight or flee and
everyone wants to use that excuse you
know we still have
all these you know biological
psychologists or people running around
saying well
it's just an impulsive thing that people
can't understand or
or or be conscious of right it's the
unconscious fears it's just
wiping us out it's like get over it
neuroscience has shown like we have much
more
powerful capabilities than most of us
think that we do and the reality is
most fear once you understand what it
actually
is and it usually is a contemplative
process
and once they understand what it is then
it's like oh we can overcome it
because what is it then i mean what is
fear what are we so scared of
what's going to hurt us what is this
thing that we fear is going to bring so
much pain in our
lives ever thought about it what is it
what is the thing that we're so scared
that's going to bring in all this pain
to our lives i remember
figuring this out for myself and when i
did
i wasn't so scared anymore because
sometimes you know the things
once you understand them more they're
not so terrifying
once something becomes knowable you can
develop competency around it once you
can develop competency around it
then you can develop confidence around
it there's this old thing in psychology
we call
the competence confidence loop the more
you understand something the more
confidence you have in that area
same thing with anything that does
happen to impulsively generate some fear
in yourself
well now once you understand what it is
you can deal with it better
because what we're all fearing is
basically three types of
pain three areas that we might
experience pain in our lives
and once we understand that we can
reorient our lot our mindset
around those things and no longer be
frustrated or stopped by fear
the first thing that we fear pain in in
our lives
is what i call lost pain loss pain is
well if i change my life or i do this
new thing
i'll experience loss and because i
experienced loss i don't want to do it
so i'm scared to try it because i might
lose something
that i like i care for i adore i might
if i go and make that big change in my
life
i might lose my job i might lose my
relationship with my spouse i
might lose my connection with my kids i
might lose a passion i might lose a
benefit
right i remember when i wanted to go and
start my own business
everyone was generating all this fear
and you might say well be careful you
know
this is very dangerous brendan you don't
you don't want to quit your job and
lose all that security you have you're
gonna i mean what about your 401k
brendan you're going to lose your 401k i
mean all these things we think we're
going to fear
and the reality was part of that was
true as i
thought more about the situation i was
concerned
i was fearful that i would lose the
security i had that the job provided
i would lose that steady paycheck we all
want i would lose that predictability of
my career path i would lose that nice
process of having managers around to
kind of coach and consult me into higher
levels of performance i would
lose the peer set i love my co-workers i
lose some of the work that i loved
i would lose that great lunch and
cafeteria
you know it's like you think of all
these things you're going to lose so you
don't make the decision to quit
same thing like people are going to try
and uh you know quit
uh you know smoking or they're going to
try and start a diet
they're fearful that they're going to
lose that that smoking break that gives
them
that peace and that comfort and that
that sense of calmness from
breathing in deep even though they're
bringing in death you know
they they're fearful oh well if i change
my diet i'm going to lose those foods
that i love so much
so i'm not going to change and that's
what people do they're
fearing loss so part of reorienting our
lives
is start focusing on the things that
instead of what we're going to lose
of what we're going to gain yeah i might
lose my security for the short term but
over the long term i might have more
freedom
i might gain freedom i i might lose that
coaching
and that that that person who's going to
develop me in terms of that
organizational structure but over here
i'm going to gain greater challenges i'm
going to grow
faster because i'm going to be doing
things faster on my own oh
you know i'm gonna lose that 401k yeah
but i'm gonna make a million dollars
over here
you know focusing on those gains see
what happens
in the in the fearful mind it starts
asking this question what if
and it follows that phrase with a
negative statement
what if this terrible thing happens what
if this terrible thing happens
what if this terrible thing happens and
we generate and we stew within our gut
these acids and these fears that
literally trick our mind
into thinking we can't change but once
you understand lost pain is something
you're dealing with
start focusing more on the things that
you will gain
and you're getting over a hurdle the
second thing that we fear
so much is what i call process pain
process pain is
changing in anything is going to be hard
the process of change
itself is hard let alone what we'll lose
doing something new
is hard when i went to think about
starting my new business
i was terrified i'm like it's going to
be hard i don't know how to do those
things yet
i don't have any competency in those
areas yet um i'm not sure
how this will go i'm gonna have to work
24 7
starting this business i'm gonna have to
work really hard for three years
i might not be able to get any support
and help the process is scary
so we don't change i mean the same thing
for that person who thinks
of quitting smoking they're not thinking
of the freedom of quitting smoking and
living healthier they're not thinking of
being able to breathe and get up the
stairs
they're thinking of the process of
dealing with
quitting the addiction the withdrawals
the frust
and outcome pain guess what the more you
focus on those the more you obsess about
those types of pain
your brain and your body goes no don't
do that i don't want to experience that
because we've built and we've been
gifted with this incredible contraption
here
that is unbelievably driven
to avoid pain and when we realize that
then we have to stop suffering in our
mind and stewing in our mind
about the pain we might experience if we
do
the very things that would improve our
lives
you and i both know what would improve
our lives why aren't we doing it
because somewhere there we've probably
associated a lot of loss process or
outcome pain to it
and today might be a great day to sit
down and say what do i
really want my life why have i not been
progressing faster
and when you start exploring that
question of why i have not been
progressing faster
you might discover loss process and pain
at work and you're going to flip it now
and focusing on
the gains the joys and the positive
outcomes
and when you start to do that you'll
find yourself being that joyous master
you'll find yourself getting further
ahead in life and you might just
find that life can feel fully charged
once again
you can do happiness it's yesterday i
didn't share you
with you my favorite metaphor of of my
entire life it's still the most
important driving metaphor
of my life in every area of my life this
is the most important metaphor
that i've learned and i've sort of owned
in my lifetime and that is this
the power plant does not have
energy
it generates energy to be more
accurate one of my students actually
taught me this is brandon actually
generate is maybe not the exact term i
said okay tell me about that
he said well what a power plant actually
does is it takes energy from
one source then it transforms
that energy into another kind of energy
then it transmits that energy which is
what you call
generating the energy that process of
transformation to transmitting i just
call it generating energy
but that's what it's doing so in the
same way we don't
have happiness we don't have joy we
don't even have
energy we are taking energy
or just consuming it and letting it land
on us
and we are transferring or transforming
that energy
into what we want to experience and
transmit in the world and that's why i
said yesterday
we have to be responsible for the energy
we bring into our families
because that's what they do especially
when they're young they don't know this
metaphor so what do they do
they just take the energy that hits them
they don't yet have the tools
to transform that energy and be who they
want to be
they just take the energy so when you
get around people who are either
unconscious
or children and sometimes it's the same
[Laughter]
you really have to manage your energy
right how many of you have ever been in
a negative mood and it completely set
off somebody
in a way you did not anticipate right
you know why that person did not have
the tools to deal with your energy
how many of you ever been that person
someone's energy completely set you
off right we've all been there but the
thing is
you got to learn how to deal with that
uh when i was in college
i got certified as a peer counselor
and i focused specifically on peer
mediation was my license
so i had peer mediation training and it
was the best thing i could ever get
because it taught me that when you get
around two people they're gonna fight
a lot and i had to mediate those
conflicts and we'll talk about some of
that
technique on sunday for you so you do
better in dealing with your conflicts
but i'd have two people and i was a an
official
permeator so i was a court referred so
they would refer i remember
i'm at this time 20 years old
court referred so i would get a couple
that was
married and going through divorce
mediation
i'm a 20 year old kid this is over 20
years ago look how
young i must have looked right oh my god
and they would come and they would
scream at each other they would just
be like freaking out on each other and i
got to deal with this
and i remember i mean my first two or
three sessions i went to my
advisor who was one of the great
communication and conflict trainers in
history bill wilmot
was my mentor and uh he wrote one of the
most important books i've ever read in
that topic
um i think it was called artful
mediation
and he said brendan you got to learn to
just be zen when other people are
fighting around you
their energy is not your energy
their energy is not your energy
you have to he told me this phrase i
never heard it ever before
he said you have to self-will
how you want to feel feel you have to
self-will
how you want to feel
and that was such a profound effect on a
20 year old kid
because at that point in my life i still
was a child i was still consuming the
energy of the world
and it could tip me off in one way or
another because i especially i grew up
around a lot of anger
so just short fuses bam short fuse bam
you're smack
short fuse bam you're in a fight very
short fuses
so that was what i had consumed and what
i was trained to so i would get angry
fast very fast all throughout high
school and all throughout college i had
martial arts training i was in fights
constantly in fights my friends and i we
would go out
and sure enough one of them would start
a fight and then they'd come and grab me
to end it
you know all throughout school i was
just
tons and tons of fights me and i'm proud
i have not been in a fight since i was
21 years old and the last fight i was in
was just to end
a fight that was happening that i could
be a service in that was it
that was it and so but i fought a lot
in my lifetime right i didn't want to do
that anymore
and part of my journey was learning to
deal with my own anger issues
my own energy that wasn't right and i
knew it wasn't right
so you have to be very conscious of your
energy and self-will it
that's why i started teaching myself i
got to learn to bring the
and i would say it over and over and
over to myself i'm like look if i'm
going to bring energy into a space it's
going to be joy
or it's going to be love and for me it's
the same thing
so i wanted for me to make sure that no
matter what i did
that was the energy i was going to bring
into space so i started training myself
on that with my phone triggers i started
training myself on that
by just deciding okay every time i walk
through a door what's the feeling
i want to bring into here one of my
doorway triggers
when i walk through a door i say to
myself i am
entering this room as a happy man
ready to serve i'm entering this room
as a happy man ready to serve
i've said that to myself tens of
thousands of times every door i walk
through
so i'm setting up a trigger cue for me
to remind myself to be happy
because if we don't remind ourselves to
happy to be happy
we won't self-will ourselves more often
to be happy
now some people say well this is just an
affirmation stupid i'm happy i'm happy
i'm
actually it's not it's something that we
know from habitual
training in behavioral sciences cue
trigger reward cue trigger reward over
and over and over again
ultimately you set up that practice it
becomes
a higher level of practice and mental
discipline
so let's return to this conversation
about happiness
if you have not had that role of
happiness
get therapeutic support but also at the
same time
start practices that will help make you
happier
and you have to teach your family to
start practices
to be your happier can be simple as a
friday night dinner where you say to the
kids what made you happy this week
you need to start giving the vocabulary
of happy
to your families you have to start
giving the vocabulary of happy
to your teams if your teams are never
talking about what makes them happy
what kind of workplace is that to be in
if you're not having conversations and
dialogues
if other people i say it to people all
the time are you happy
how's it going are you happy how's it
going i ask it all the time
are you happy how's it going because by
asking the question
i'm cueing it just like the doorway
frigger
doorway trigger i enter this room as a
happy man
ready to serve and when i say i enter
this room
as a happy man ready to serve it makes
me more intentional
makes me more what and these little
triggers that you set up in your life
it makes you more intentional
like you you those little reminders they
mean so much to us
we forget to do them but your happiness
is important
your happiness is very important just
like your self-identity is important
just like how you want to treat people
all of that is incredibly important we
just forget to set up those triggers how
many of you could do a better job
setting up your life
for some happiness at this stage of your
life yeah tell the person left right
shake them say you deserve to be happy
to do it you just have to be a little
more
intentional and sometimes to be
intentional
you just need a reminder
[Applause]
how many just had their alarm go off to
say that's me
turner vs left right shake him say be
more intentional
so let's talk about procrastination
right now and just have a conversation
about what it means
you know procrastination basically means
that you are
not doing what you know you need to do
when you know you need to do it
it's putting things off because in the
short term
it's easier it's more comfortable it's
more certain
it's more pleasurable to be distracted
or to indulge yourself doing something
else than it is to sit down and do the
actual
work to create the outputs that matter
when they are needed and i know that
every single one of us
procrastinates me too so it's okay
the issue is can you set yourself up so
you do less of it
i believe you can so let's talk about
procrastination in this way
three brain hacks number one simple
you're more likely to do something if
you have
already prepared and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already prepared
and stepped it through what does that
mean it means
if you want to not procrastinate on
monday
sunday night i want you to sit down and
do this simple little thing
project plan i know it's not sexy
please don't make fun of me right now
it's not sexy i know it's not sexy
and it will change your life forever the
day before
the days in which it's required that you
really get stuff done i want you to sit
down
and project plan i don't mean tomorrow
write down your to-do lists
that is one element of project planning
but i want a bigger picture i want you
to be thinking about
the big projects that you have coming up
and i want you to have
written out these steps that it's going
to take the big steps that we'll take to
accomplish this project
and this project and this project with a
timeline for each of them
and then work backwards from that to
create tomorrow's to-do lists
but here's what's funny if listen list
if your mind can't see completion
if your mind cannot see completion
meaning you don't know the path
you don't have clarity on the path to
fulfill or complete something
if your mind can't see the steps
your heart will ask to pause
if your mind can't see
the project through the completion your
heart will ask to pause
even if you're the most passionate dream
oriented
amazing high performer in the world but
you yank away someone's clarity
you know no goals no growth
no clarity no change and so if you find
yourself procrastinating
it might not even you might be like but
brandon i hate myself i procrastinate
and i even know the next three things i
should do i go not enough
knowing your next three steps is not
enough
your mind needs to see all the steps
through to completion
and that's what we call project planning
it's not super fun but it's saying okay
this is the big project here the big key
activities the big buckets of activities
that would have to happen to get it done
here's the timelines those big buckets
have to happen
okay then these big buckets of
activities those have been broken down
into tasks
and then into ultimately daily to do's
and if we don't have that like it's just
hard to act when you don't have a
complete picture
right you're kind of like uh
procrastinating let me give you a
metaphor
you know they've timed people about how
long it takes them
to complete a puzzle so if i show up at
your house
and i give you a big puzzle box and
there's 400 pieces in it
and we set it out on your table
and we watch how long different time
periods takes to complete it
you know the fastest most productive
time in which people are putting puzzles
together
the last twenty percent if you've ever
done a puzzle right
you might walk by it three four times
for a couple weeks you don't do anything
you put a few pieces together
but as soon as the picture becomes a
little more clear guess what you do
you hunker down and you complete it
don't you
that's what's going on procrastination
even if you see the first couple pieces
it's just like if you can't see where
it's going
your your heart will go pause
i'm unsure i'm scared i don't know what
to do
that's just how we think right that part
of our brain that is trying to protect
us
that part of our heart that says i want
to do good i want to care for other
people and do things with excellence
all of a sudden those are compromised
when we don't do the most basic thing
so if there's an important project
you've been procrastinating in
do yourself the greatest gift i can give
you today
and that is tonight sit down with your
journal and step it all the way out
even if you have to make it up even if
you're like i'm not sure this is
actually
the big activities it it's not about
having the perfect
project plan it's having one that is
completed
at least the knowledge you know now
because then your brain go okay let's
get into this and keep making this thing
better but your brain won't get into it
if you haven't project planned so this
is really important what i do
to avoid procrastination each week is
every single sunday for me that's my
sunday review days sunday work days
i'll sit down and i'll literally step
through the entire week of all the major
things on my
email or on my to-do list i'll think
about the bigger projects
and i'll just kind of step it all the
way through and guess what
i enter the week more engaged
more joyous and confident because i know
what the heck is going on
so if you keep procrastinating i promise
if it's not
lots of worry or it's not you know lots
of randomness
it's you haven't seen it through yet
other brain hack very related but a
little different and more
immediate and you'll love this one so
number two is this
and it's so basic but i'm going to test
you and see how often you've been doing
it
and that is visualize remember i said
you won't do it if your brain can't see
it step through well here's specifically
what i do to make sure i don't
procrastinate
i literally visualize
and affirm what i'm about to go do
so if it's sunday and i'd say okay
you know tomorrow in the afternoon i've
got all these things
i can procrastinate because i'm the only
one holding myself accountable and i
could say well you know what um
let's see here how would i avoid that
i will sit down and i'll do this 20 30
minutes a day
visualizing the next day or that morning
i'll sit down and visualize the day and
i'll just step it through i'll say okay
let me see myself going into the kitchen
getting my little green tea going over
to the office
sitting down at the computer opening up
that
blank page happily typing along
sensing and feeling those great emotions
of doing
my calling as a writer let me
feel the power and the joy of finishing
a great day of writing
let me imagine myself going to dinner
getting to sit down
with my wife and saying honey here's
what i did today
i wrote this part of the book let me
hear
see and feel that interaction with her
happiness and her joy
that i'm doing my path let me imagine
myself going to bed that night
happy that you know what i did what i'm
here to do
now i don't know what you're calling
yours or what you feel like you should
be doing but
for me that simple little activity of
just literally walking the entire day
through
not just one thing i do this with with
mega
athletes all the time i say listen i
don't want you to just imagine the fight
i want you to visualize yourself on the
way over to the arena
i want you to see visualize yourself
getting laced up i want you to visualize
yourself
on the walk down to the ring entering
the ring your first feelings walking
around the ring
the sense that you will have as you're
in that fight
that sense that you have when you're
getting beaten in that fight and how
you're gonna feel and respond
to that because visualization is not
just happy-go-lucky it's also like
okay see yourself what do you do when
there's a struggle
so i for me okay what do i do when i get
writer's block how do how does the
brendan dealing with writer's block
deal with that and i'll see it i'll
imagine myself
getting back at it and i'll see it
through
how's it feel when you win how does it
feel after the wind how does it feel at
the end of the day
how does it feel when you finally lay
your head onto your pillow
and go to bed that is a full day
visualization on the things that matter
the most for your productivity
and i want you to do that at least
either the night before
or the day of the morning of and what
will happen
these two things together as i know you
might say brand that's so basic
but okay did you do it last night
because
i've found as a high performance coach
sometimes it is not the big crazy things
it's that people aren't doing the
fundamentals and they want me to support
brandon changed my life i go okay
let's change your life let's be
accountable did you do these things last
night
so don't tell me it's too basic this is
me challenging and being honest
did you do these two things last night
if you did
give yourself a shout out down below and
celebrate yourself good for you
if you're not doing this consistently
that is why you are consistently
procrastinating my friend i know
sometimes
life change can be so basic and you go
duh
why haven't i been doing that but those
ones are really
important as a coach for me to call out
for you because i know a lot of people
who could be so much more effective if
they got back to the fundamentals
let me share this last one with you so
first brain hack
project plan day before
step it all the way through day before
or the morning of visualize
the entire process of the day and you
doing it well
even if you meet uncertainty fear
struggle
hardship and the last piece is the other
brain hack
don't forget that not only do we need
order
not only do we need the creativity and
the visualization we're also social
animals
so i want you to socialize your agenda
with other people socialize your agenda
with other people
what does that mean well it's just the
same you know at this time of year a lot
of people are trying to lose some weight
or trying to go to the gym and what's
the first advice everyone always gives
them because it's proven by science to
work over and over and over again
get a workout buddy because if you've
got a workout buddy
you'll show up it's harder to
procrastinate
when your name your integrity your
relationships
are on the line and so you need to
tell people about what you have to do
like you'd probably be annoyed hanging
out with me because i like if we went
out to dinner
i'd probably tell you like 10 things i'm
going to do tomorrow
and i'm not telling you that because i
love to talk about work
i know if i speak it it will become more
real the next day
if i don't affirm it and share it with
other people it's just in my head
i'm just not gonna be as productive and
i do know without question
this is a big issue for a lot of people
they're
stay-at-home moms they're work from home
entrepreneurs
they're you know the senior leader in
their company
who does a lot of status things but they
don't themselves
get to talk through a lot of things and
i can't tell you how important it is
to speak through the reality that you
want
right these things you could certainly
do on your own
but if you share these things with other
people and you socialize that agenda
all of a sudden you won't procrastinate
because you know that you've put it out
there
other people are going to hold you
accountable or even just more
sometimes talking something through
makes you want to do it more
literally they found in psychological
studies just speaking out your goals
makes it more likely that you will take
consistent action on those goals
literally just speaking it and they've
even done it where they took out other
people
they just made someone stand in a booth
with a microphone
and speak out what they were going to do
they were more likely
to do that than if they just kept it in
their head and didn't speak it
so if you're like brandon i got nobody
who believes my dreams
i'm like well i bet you have a friend
and you could facetime them or skype
them
and talk through it it is so important
for you to
speak through your dreams
than you can probably ever imagine and a
lot of people keep that stuff to
themselves
because what they're worried how they
look
so now imagine all these things
colliding on the opposite
you're worried how you look so you don't
tell anybody
so you're not socially accountable and
you have no social cheerleading
you're worried what other people will
think so in your brain you go
well if other people are going to think
i'm crazy why even do this
i mean that's a risk so i might look
stupid if i do
so now your brain goes well why even
imagine this for yourself anymore
then your brain says well if you can't
imagine it for yourself anymore
why would you even plan it and if you
can't imagine it you can't plan it
and other people might think you're
stupid why don't you go find something
else to do like netflix
or shopping or hanging out or indulging
yourself in some other hobbies
that aren't relevant to what you're
trying to do
aka let's procrastinate because we're
worried
you see all these tied together so the
brain hacks
are to set yourself up so that you have
more confidence
and routine and structure going in
these are the three ways as a recap
project plan
night before week before day of i don't
care
but the if you can do it the day before
it sets it mentally in your brain
and you have a little more confidence in
it definitely visualize the night before
or day of
all the time and the last piece is
socialize it
you've got to start sharing your
thoughts your dreams
your agenda what you're going to do with
other people and if you do those three
things
your brain will be more optimized and
more likely
to get in the game and get stuff done so
i hope
in sharing my experience with you you
understand how important these four
things are
to your success number one is
competence competence it means
you should focus on getting absolutely
competent
at the skills that matter for your
long-term success
whatever your dream is think of it what
like what's your dream break it down and
say okay if i if that's my dream
what skills would i have to master
really master to be able to have that
dream for me as an example
speaking with you right now i don't know
how many of my videos you've watched or
whatever but
you know we've had a quarter billion
video views
and i was mortified to speak
some of you guys have been in my
seminars before like 2 000 people 10 000
people
30 000 people in an arena i was
mortified i was terrified to get up and
speak in front of people
and so you're like well how did you
develop that and learn that well
i had this dream to make a difference in
the world
and i wanted to impact a lot of people
in the world and i said if i'm actually
going to help a lot of people in the
world
i need to learn how to communicate
because where i grew up
there wasn't a lot of emotional
expression or a lot of communication
i mean if a dude raised his hand in an
emotional expression above his waist and
he was gonna punch you in the face
that's where i grew up with i didn't
grow up with people being like
outwardly expressive and joyous and like
facial expressions and moving their
hands i didn't grow up with that
i had to learn like how do i communicate
and and make an
impact with people and share what i want
to share i had to practice that and
learn that but i had to become
competent in that if i wanted to make my
difference
and i think that's really important the
greats master their skills think of any
musician you love
they mastered their art their voice
their instrument
think about any person you really admire
in business they had to master business
building they had to master
the process or the product or the thing
think about anyone you admire in their
health and
wellness they had to master their own
body think about the happiest people you
know they had to master their mind
how did they do that they learned they
studied
they studied they studied they applied
they applied they applied
competence is the thing that we know in
high performance gives people the edge
when you are more informed more educated
more experienced
in the things that matter most to your
career you outperform everybody else
who's just going through the motions
who's just showing up but when you're
learning in those dark hours of the
night
when you are trying when nobody else is
watching and you are developing
skill guess what we know from psychology
that competence and confidence
are very correlated we call it high
performance work
the competence confidence loop right
the more you learn the more you're
willing to try
and the more you're willing to try the
greater confidence you gain
the more confidence you gain the more
you're willing to try
new things which teaches you even more
so this
confidence competence loop is the secret
to lifelong success keep learning keep
applying because as you master new
skills that
matter to the direction of your life
towards your dreams
then you get more confident as you get
more confident you try new things
and you get more success number two and
this is really key
a contribution mindset to not begin the
day
with me me me not to look at your life
with i hope to get this i hope to
survive
take your mind off survival take your
mind off getting for yourself
and ask how can i give right it's
biblical
to ask you know and you shall receive
but also it's ethical to give
and you shall receive when you change
your mindset from getting
to giving when you change your mindset
to contribute
when you think about your day your work
your mission your life
as a way to contribute instead of going
into work to complain about your job
washing dishes you say how can i go do
this
and help contribute to my team help
contribute to somebody else's day
help everyone else who's working in the
kitchen let's all
have a great day contribute positivity
contribute
like energy to the world because even if
you're not doing great things yet
you can do the little things with
greatness if you approach it with the
mindset
of service like the contribution mindset
is what always makes the difference
because think about it
is it true that some people become
really successful
rich famous and you know have everything
outwardly that everyone wants
but it's still miserable it's because
they're not
feeling the satisfaction and the
fulfillment
of service they did everything they
needed
to get something they became something
but they never felt fulfilled because
they didn't utilize that or along the
way
give and serve others the contribution
mindset can change your life
for me what i learned along the way too
is the third c
is about community and
where i grew up i didn't have a lot of
people who are trying to really better
themselves
i know and i appreciate you because
you're here for your personal
development
people watch my videos because they want
personal professional development
and so i appreciate you being here i
call you guys team
hpx hpx stands for high performance
experience because i believe
that not everybody wants to live the
high performance experience not
everybody wants to reach the next level
not everybody wants that extraordinary
vibrancy and
and connection and excellence that comes
from trying to be your best
but those of you who do why you're here
my belief about team hpx about us
is we've learned we have to build the
tribe necessary
to succeed and enjoy life you can't just
take
the energy and the people you have in
your life you need to strategically
build the people around you to have the
community you need to succeed
and enjoy life and often that brings up
for people well
but brendan my spouse doesn't support me
you know people make fun of me the kids
at school don't understand
the people at work shoot down my ideas
and it's not that you have to kick
everybody out who's negative it's not
that you have to get rid of all these
people because
sometimes that person is is your spouse
or your brother or your sister or your
friend
it's not you have to get rid of them or
judge them in any way
what you can do is limit your time and
exposure to them
and even if you can't do that because
that's the person who you are in love
with right now
what you can do is separately build what
you need
in other words successful people build
the community they need
they don't hope to have it they're not
born from it they don't always have it
in their
in their current circle but what they do
is they go build it
so ask what's your dream what do you
really want to achieve
and what's the type of people you need
to be around
to have that experience that and
accelerate towards that
for me i had to start shaping new
friendships
i had to do more networking in my
industry to meet new people
i had to get myself around others i went
to seminars and workshops
networking events i got myself around
high achievers
i wasn't born around many of them i had
to get myself around them
and by getting myself in that proximity
of a peer group that was
positive ambitious service oriented
competent at what they do it raised my
game
right other people can really inspire
you so build the community you need
and i think the last thing that i've
learned that's so important
is that successful people take command
of their life they took command of their
thoughts
command of their emotions they take
command of what they're doing during the
day
they're less reactive than other people
because they say i'm going to be the
captain of my ship
and that sense of command is the
difference maker in their lives
where most people they take their
circumstances they blame
they complain they dread the struggle
people who've taken command of their
lives they honor the struggle
they bring the joy they decide what
their day is going to be about they work
diligently towards their dreams
instead of being distracted or run by
impulse
they are focused and they choose
discipline like they have commanded
their life
at levels most people don't because
listen you and i both listen
anyone can have a bad day and come home
and be like i you know what
bad day netflix and chill and they give
up their day or their next four hours
to tuning out what i learned about
successful people
is when it is struggle when it's easy to
be discouraged when it's easy to go i
guess netflix and chill they go no
man you know you had a bad day so take
command do something positive for
yourself
take the next two hours and create work
connect
be with the family like they reset
themselves
consistently and that's what i mean by
command
right because we can't control
everything is it true
we can't control everything some days
someone's gonna be a jerk to you some
days the project's gonna fall apart
some days it's not going to go the way
that you want
but what successful people do in those
moments
is they reconnect to their personal
power and say okay what did i learn
what can i do next what's my next right
action of integrity
they take command of themselves so they
don't let themselves feel sorry for
themselves they take command of
themselves don't let other people tell
them exactly what to do
they say what should i do now
versus i guess i'll give up have you
ever wanted to quit a job
or quit a career or quit a school or
leave
town and go to another city or you know
stop doing a hobby or something you've
done for so long and you're known for
doing that but you're like i just don't
want to do this anymore but you couldn't
quit
i mean psychologically you're just like
i can't stop doing that and you really
wanted to but you just couldn't
or do you know anybody who needs to do
that you know you know somebody who you
know they need to leave a relationship
or they need to leave a situation that's
not healthy for them but they just can't
even though they want to
let's talk about that because so many
people have a big stigma
about quitting and it prevents them from
living a fully charged life
you know they're going through their day
with drudgery or dread
or they just feel like they're a cog in
the machine and not really feeling alive
and joyous
they don't feel like they're really
connected or engaged with what they're
doing but they feel like they have
to keep doing it and so they stay on
this treadmill
that never ends and at some point it
becomes miserable
and we have to in our society get over
this belief
that you know quitting is necessarily a
bad thing and i know that's crazy for me
to be saying right the achievement guy
this the self-help guy here with the
show and all of my books on on personal
development growth
where so much of it is really about
setting a vision being disciplined
working towards it
and you know busting your ass until that
dream comes true
so i'm not known for saying hey quit but
you know if something isn't right
in your life and it's not bringing you
that charge of of
engagement and enthusiasm each day
making you feel like it's something
that's
meaningful and it's fulfilling to you
then yeah
you're darn right you should look at
quitting that you know so many people
have this big stigma to it but it's
necessary
sometimes to stop doing the things that
are not right for us
so that we can open up some white space
so that the universe
can throw in some new opportunities or
we can go grasp
some new things because as you've heard
me probably say before only two things
are going to change your life
either a something new comes into your
life a new
opportunity a new dream a new goal a new
desire a new person
a new job whatever it is something new
comes in you win the lottery
and that changes the course of your life
forever or
something new comes from within you
it's not external it's internally
something new a new courage
a new vision a new belief a new desire a
new willingness to go out there and try
something new
that will be fulfilling for you so it's
okay if something is not right
if something is wrong the goal should be
you know what let's change that
if you really take an introspective look
at that and you know it's not right for
you
then change needs to come and it needs
to come sooner than you're probably
prepared for
because what the world usually does is
they say you know what uh brendan
i need a sign before i can change you
know i know
i know i want to change it but i'm
waiting for a sign well you know what
the sign is
the sign is that you're waiting for a
sign to change
that's the sign if you've been wondering
should i change
if you're like i'm waiting for something
to happen and that will change
that's the signal that's your brain
saying hey dummy this isn't right
keep looking out for something to change
right now because we need a new reason
we need an excuse
that's the sign the sign is the sign so
if you have any
part of you you're like i need to change
and i'm hoping something comes in to
change my life
no no no you gotta listen to your
internal intuition
to your body to your soul saying man i
have to change
and it has to be i have to change you're
going to have to change
your situation no white night is going
to come in no big
fancy new job opportunity might sweep in
and change everything for you unless
you're out there looking for them
yeah some people get lucky but you know
the number of people who are lucky in
the world
is this finite tiny little strand of
people who are only lucky once in a
while
the reality is most of us are out there
working
for our dreams and i know you're doing
that too so if something's not right
be okay with it you know be okay with
quitting you know i love this uh quote
from arianna huffington a friend of mine
who
as you know with the founder of
huffington post she says this great
thing she says
sometimes the best way to finish a
project
is to quit you know we have this
type a behavior in us that says well i
have to
perfect this thing or i have to get this
thing just right before i can leave it
you know no you don't not everything has
to be perfect
before you leave something if it's just
not right
i mean yes leave it with as much grace
as you can but get out
sooner than later no one at the end of
their life says gosh
i wish i hadn't changed my life for the
better so
soon you know what they say is i wish i
hadn't waited so long
to follow my dreams i wish i hadn't
waited so long to
approach that person i wanted to
approach i wish i hadn't waited so long
to learn those skills to
develop that new thing to start that
project
it's about beginning it's about
beginning sooner than you're probably
ready for and that's where this idea of
courage comes into life
knowing that you know you might not know
how it's going to turn out
you might not have any idea if it's if
it's going to be
something that's as good as you have now
and that's where
real courage and trust and faith comes
into play
that says you know what you're competent
you will figure it out
right the first rule of life i will say
is have vision for your life
the second rule is trust in your ability
to figure things out you'll figure it
out
trust in that so here's a couple things
not to do
one don't wait for the perfect timing
the perfect timing is never going to
come because there's no such thing as
perfect
there's never going to be a day where
you wake up you're like this is the
perfect day for me to finally change
all the things have lined up my inbox is
completely clear
i have nothing to do today there's no
distractions
the kids are finally perfectly on their
own oh my gosh my husband or wife is
finally perfect on their own
everybody is healthy around me
everything is just perfect the day is
sunny and bright
and oh my gosh look at all this gold
that just happened to appear in front of
me
it's not going to happen like that you
need to say okay
there is never going to be a perfect
time so you need to set a d-day
literally a day in which you say that's
the day and then you need to marshal
all of your motivation all of your
ability to learn and develop skills as
fast as you can
before that day but when that day comes
that's d-day that's the day that you go
that's the
you quit and that has to be a real date
for you
when you mark it on the calendar that's
the day you quit the thing
that's the day you walk out that's the
day that you leave that situation that
is not healthy
or satisfying or good for you or your
soul or the people around you
that you have to have that date it has
to be scheduled
or you'll never do it you'll just keep
saying oh you know one day things are
gonna be
you know the people who say one day they
end up at the end with a collection of
days
that were so far from perfect that
they're in a state of misery now they
never landed in their
in the land of their dreams because they
were always marching
in something that was miserable to them
right at some point
the only way the life change is that you
change your course
and don't wait for a perfect day so
what's your date
what's your date some people will say
well brandon my date's five years from
now or the
ultimate um you know when the kids
graduate high school or when they finish
college or now when they get the jobs or
now when they move on the couch
you know whatever the thing is that
people come up with no no you need to
have the date
and that's the day just like when we had
to enter world war ii if we're here in
the united states
we had d-day normandy we knew we were
going to go the weather was not perfect
the days were not perfect the lead up to
was not perfect we didn't have all the
supplies we didn't have everything we
needed but there was something
that was calling us to serve and there
was a critical crisis and we needed to
go and we made it happen
that date was real and it had to happen
you need to have a date what is it
if it's more than three years out you're
fooling yourself
there is nothing that you cannot
significantly change i mean complete
transformation in your life
three years out from now i mean if you
just thought about it think about all
the knowledge
the skills the social support you could
set up in three years
personally and maybe this isn't for you
but this is what i tell all my clients
and
many of you know my clients literally
millions of dollars in exchange
for coaching for training for working
with me personally
and then able to do that i tell them all
they got six months
that's it there's a something needs to
change in their life i'll let them set a
six-month deadline and that's it
because you know what in six months i
mean trust in your bill you could learn
so much in six months you can develop so
many new skills
in six months you can interview so many
new people in the new area you want to
change into
in six months if you got dedicated if it
had to happen in six months
i mean if your butt was on the line you
would make it happen
there's nothing beyond that six months
everything beyond six months in our
lives is an excuse
i mean come on we can all change
radically in six months
it's not popular to say because everyone
wants to say no it's gonna take years of
therapy and years of medication
you know maybe that's true for some
people with psychological or biological
disorders that prevent them
from being in full grasp of their life
but for the vast majority
there's an unbelievable amount of
conscious control in their life and
there's an unbelievable amount of
discipline
and strength in them if they would unlet
it
so what is your date what is it you want
to change
what skills would you have to develop by
that date what social support and
structure would you have to develop
by that date what resources would you
have to go acquire
learn borrow or build from before that
date
without that type of thinking without
that d-day without that plan
it's just gonna be wistful thinking and
most people go through so much of their
life
wish we'll think and then they look back
they're like i lost a decade of their
life
of their life so take it seriously
you know and don't wait for not only
that perfect timing
don't wait for permission you don't need
anybody to give you permission
to change your life if you've been
waiting for someone to give you
permission i have good news
the universe and god already gave it to
you it's called
free will it came with you at birth for
free you didn't have to buy it it was
just right there in your pocket
now it's just about why don't you take
it out use it free will is the ultimate
gift
you don't need the permission of anybody
to change your life
what we always tell ourselves is uh i
need i i you know i need my spouse to
prove
i need this person to prove i need these
50 people to prove and i'm not saying
that we can't attempt to enroll people
and enlist them in our own visions and
our dreams
and i can't i'm not saying that often
we're not all on the same journey
together
right you and your spouse and your
partner your loved ones your kids
like you're all in the same journey
together but this idea that everybody
needs to approve of every single move
that you make is ridiculous
maybe you're in a career and you're
known for something and you're thinking
i can't change this career because you
know my customers won't like it
i can't change my message right now
because these people know me for that
you know i work with some of the world's
top celebrities and to tell you what if
everyone can change on a dime
everybody can change their message
everybody can change what they're about
if it's more meaningful to them
and purposeful and true for them follow
your truth
not the permissions given by a fickle
society
follow your truth and last i'll say this
you know sometimes all this it does
require a lot of courage
to set that date to work towards it to
know you're gonna get resistance from
other people towards that but what's the
choice what's the alternative
the alternative is to live a life that's
not your own
and that's ultimate misery the ultimate
feeling in life that everybody's after
this charge is this internal spark some
some people might call it happiness some
people call it fulfillment
some people just call it enthusiasm or
excitement or engagement whatever it is
for you
that comes from doing things on a
regular basis that you're engaged with
that you care for
and if you're in a position where that's
not your reality it's time to change
it will require trust it will require
faith it will require an
extraordinary amount of courage and
those things you already
have why don't you go out and show the
world those things
why don't you go out and show yourself
those things it's time for a change
it's time to feel better about your life
and do more of the things that you care
about
and that you love if you needed
permission i just gave it to you
you really didn't need me to say
anything what you needed was to hear it
and to sit down and go
what's that date and so what happens
when you get that date
is it going to be easy no but why is
everyone so after this comfortable easy
life
you know life that growth and that
maturity that enlightenment that
transformation
that zest that joy it comes from
struggle it comes from working through
things and growing and
learning and confidence let's celebrate
learning again
it's okay set that date don't get oh
that day's gonna be so scary it's gonna
be
wow that day is gonna start a new
journey for me i'm gonna learn
so much welcome the struggle welcome
the hardship know that it's not gonna be
easy see in my life i go about i'm like
you know what this is gonna be hard i
don't know how this is gonna turn out
but i'm gonna be
the best of who i am to it i'm gonna be
the best of my intentions i'm gonna show
up for it
be fully present and engage with it and
i'll do my best and i don't always do
awesome
and neither will you you're gonna hit
that date and it's gonna be a hot
mess it's gonna be sloppy scary
uncertain
unknown and god it's gonna be great set
your date my friends
go work towards it with verve and just
passion and fire and excitement
because on that day things will start to
be so
much better you'll start to feel that
aliveness and engagement with life again
you'll start to feel
the charge life how do you stay focused
answering this question is perhaps the
most important
critical thing you will ever do in your
lifetime
period so i hope it is an absolute
priority for you to learn to take back
your focus in life
for you to get more distinct and more
clear about what your focus really is
and for you to finally decide you know
what if i don't finally get my focus in
check if i keep
wandering around distracted if i keep
looking at every new thing that pops up
if i keep trying every single new
opportunity if i keep saying yes to
everything
if i keep listening to everybody's
complaints and if i keep doing whatever
they ask me to do
at some point you'll lose your life and
i don't mean that
physically as in harm or death i mean
that one day you'll wake up and say
i don't feel like i've accomplished
what's meaningful to me i don't feel
like i'm in a job that i care for
i don't feel like i have connection with
my family or my friends
because at some point your focus drives
everything it drives your thoughts and
your emotions
right what you focus on is certainly if
you focus on the negative things you're
going to be negative
if you focus on if you fail to focus on
the things that are important
meaning your priorities then what
happens to your relationships
what happens is overall quality of your
life focus is driving
everything in your life you got to get
it back it's not just about being
productive we'll talk about that
it's about experiencing the best quality
of life
you hear this new movement called the
mindfulness movement
right about the new popularity of these
conversations about
presence and meditation and and things
like myself and my industry have been
talking about for decades
well you hear about that that's really
just about reigning back
in control of our focus in a world
that's gone mad and crazy and distracted
so how are you going to get your focus
back
well let me give you some
counter-intuitive ways to do it the
first thing that i need you to know
in order to get your focus back is to
realize that you need to make
fewer decisions
fewer decisions why well as we know in
from neuroscience and we
know from productivity studies that the
more decisions that we actually make
the more our brain becomes fatigued
right the more decisions that we make
the more we utilize the glucose that's
really fueling
our willpower that's fueling our
frankly our ability to make more
decisions and higher quality decisions
matter of fact the more decisions that
you tend to make the less effective
you're going to be over the long term
because you're going to utilize your
ability and your resources and your
brain's power
literally your willpower will go out the
window
so you want to minimize the number of
decisions you are making
how do you do that well here's some
simple things one
stop browsing you know i know maybe you
found me because you were browsing
somewhere
and i hope you make me part of your your
your focus on your personal development
that i'm a purposeful part of your life
but i can tell you
overall browsing completely wipes out
your focus and your willpower even all
these little things you're focusing on
are utilizing all your brain's resources
and over a period of time when you stop
browsing
and you go back to focusing on something
guess what
you tend not to be able to focus on one
thing and get things done you start
multitasking and doing lots of things
but where your work isn't really focused
nothing gets accomplished
so what happens is your brain is
fatigued guess what happens your brain
fatigue
you find yourself sitting with a bag of
data chips and what do you do when you
have remote control
you're just flipping randomly through
things do you ever notice that
meaning it's easier to become distracted
the more distracted you are meaning the
more
that you aren't focusing on one thing at
a time
the more problem you're going to have
later on to complete
one thing at a time and i know that
makes sense
but here's this simple solution if you
missed it stop browsing so much
all those browsing all those tweets that
you're reading all those news feeds that
you're reading
guess what every time you look at them
guess what your mind has to do
it has to make a decision pay attention
or not pay attention
and that decision is costing you focal
power and resources later on
even if you don't know it now some
people say well brandon i study
neuroscience too and but all those
little things i see those are
firing off my dopamine am i by
suppressing them i'm getting excited
because
i'm seeing all these things my mind
feels rewarded by seeing all these
things making all these decisions
and it is true that's why it's such a
frenzy and it becomes so addictive
but it also becomes so fatiguing and if
you're constantly fatiguing your brain
by focusing on a million things you'll
never get your focused
power back does that make sense so stop
making so
many decisions by stop browsing things
to decide whether or not you should pay
attention to them just stop
browsing when you do things do then do
them intentional
if you're looking for something search
for that one thing find it you're out
stop clicking on all the blue links stop
swiping all the apps and all the
pictures
do the things that are going to move you
forward well what should those things be
that leads us to point number two here
which is you must define
your mission you need to have a mission
for what you're doing today you need to
have an intention for what your next
task is going to be what happens most
people just kind of show up and they go
okay well i guess i'll
do some stuff but they have no intention
whatsoever
so they end up doing too many things
that mean nothing
towards their mission you should figure
out what is it you desire in life
and figure out the steps to get there
and start working a plan
to get there and minimizing everything
else getting very clear on the mission
very clear on the mission and working
the plan
everything else guess what it gets a no
until you reach that mission or until
you're significantly on your way
that you have free resources to be able
to focus elsewhere
and that's what people do they take on
too many projects because they're not
clear about their
mission because i'm guessing if you're
watching this you know
you're somebody who wants to add value
and make a difference in the world so
anytime someone asks you to do something
yeah let me help you but
that might not have anything to do with
the quality of life
or the objective or the thing that
you're trying to achieve
or the service you're really intending
to offer right
and i know how hard it is because i'm so
pulled myself towards causes and towards
volunteerism towards helping so many
people
but guess what if i help everybody in
lots of different areas
i might not make my ultimate mission
of serving the people i want to serve
the most of making
my dreams come true so i could support
more people of running my business so i
can support
more people meaning it's easy to take
your eye off the ball
if you don't know what the ball is and
people often have never defined their
mission
and if you don't have one right now for
this day if you didn't have a
drive a mission a written down statement
about what you were going to accomplish
today
a checklist a goal sheet a time
management tool
that you filled out today and you're
just showing up today and going well i
guess i'll see what my inbox tells me to
do today
and you just respond to everybody else's
desires
and everyone else's emails and you're
just always in reaction
always responding to everybody no
proactivity towards a mission that you
defined yourself
you'll be lost you'll find that
because you never focused on that one
thing or moving towards those several
things that were your priority
that you're just lost because and here's
another thing
focus goes out the window when we don't
have progress
right if we're not progressing towards
something our focus goes out the window
we just we just don't pay attention to
anything we don't feel good about
ourselves
you want to get more focus in your life
get more progress as you progress more
you start to get excited you start to
pay attention to things that are working
that are moving you forward
and you start to find more focus in your
life last idea it's
so very very very simple
and i hope that you will practice it i
hope that you will study it
i hope that you will work it over and
over and over and over again
once you have that mission your job
is to try this just for a little while i
know it's gonna be uncomfortable and
you're gonna hate the idea
especially coming from me and that is i
just want you to say no
to everything immediately from now on
always
now that goes against the grain of a lot
of people say well no no life is about
saying yes
well yeah a lot of people said yes to
everything and that's why they're
miserable
i want you to say no just at first just
so you can check it
against your mission i don't want you to
say yes or commit to any projects
immediately anymore that's what people
do i do want you to commit
but just give yourself like a a couple
hour break or a night
an evening's break make the decision the
next day right if something comes up and
you can do it
and you're excited about it and and
someone asks you to do something
i just say just say no first it will
teach you to say
no i'm going to evaluate that first i'm
going to put some thought to this to see
should i focus on this right now in my
life yes or no
and build some criteria for yourself you
know if you think about the time
energy resources and effort and sanity
you're you're gonna have to put into
something
well you should get something more out
of it than you put in right you should
be able to draw
you know some some some return on
investment or future value out of it or
your own personal development or your
improvement to your lifestyle from it
but if you're gonna give yourself if
you're gonna focus on something
make sure it's gonna lead to some kind
of result even if just that result is
your true passion your true love and
your true spirit in it otherwise
it's got to get a no and what this
suggests is that we have to have
a greater degree of evaluative time
and evaluative criteria in our life if
we're ever going to truly have focus
right most people because they're just
saying yes to everything and they never
filter something through criteria to say
yes no good for me bad for me right now
wrong now because they have no criteria
they have no
basis for making the decision they've
said yes to too many things
their play has become too full and now
there's too much to focus on
so they're not even moving forward your
job
is to get back to a very simple
level of life to very simple
things to focus on to do you know to
focus what we call essentialism
or simplicity to just make sure that
you're only focusing on one or two
major things at a time and everything
else you're not allowing the
distractions to suck you in so you click
all the links or do all the things that
someone else says or reply to everybody
else
but you're moving your life forward day
by day
little by little engage in things that
you care about that you love that you
enjoy
saying no to those that you do not and
move towards every single day
moment by moment day by day to those
things that truly engage you to those
things that
truly energize you and bring enthusiasm
into your life and if you can keep that
type of focal power and intention
then you'll start to experience what we
call the charged life
if you've ever sensed there's something
that you need to stop
or quit but you didn't know if it was
the right time or
or you know do you leave the
relationship or the job or the career or
the dream like
when how long to stay with something
you're going to love
this training so what i'm gonna do is
i'm just gonna cut you into
that live training that i just did and i
hope that you will enjoy it again it
just teaches that first habit but it's
so
powerful so make sure you bust out your
journal and watch this
quit the wrong thing now
this one surprised me when you talk with
the world's highest performers they have
a pretty obvious pattern
of quitting and frankly they quit faster
than other people
and it is a habit it is an actual
observable
pattern and when i did our structured
interviews through the high performance
institute with these people
it was so obvious that they were very
conscious of what was wrong for them and
what was right for them
and when it was wrong man they cut and
run
they were gone out of that situation i
mean it was fast
most of us because we want to be good
people and we want to be
thorough and perfectionist and our
follow through
it's important we learn all those things
and and perseverance is
everything we're taught right yes that's
true
and perseverance is very important to
initial success
but long-term success you know it's kind
of like
when you're going for your initial level
of success you say yes to almost
everything
because you're learning about yourself
what's right for you what's wrong for
you
you're taking on new opportunities to
see how they pan out but once you have
that baseline level of success and you
want to go up there
to a new level you got to start sorting
and deleting faster than other people
usually do you know most people hang on
to
things too long they hang on to
regret too long anger
too long hurt to hang on to it
too long they hang on to a business idea
that just isn't right for them it's not
bringing passion or joy
or income hang on into it too long
and i share this is an advanced thing
because quitting is terrifying
um it's scary and
identifying something is the wrong thing
it takes a lot of guts because then you
gotta admit
man i've been focused on the wrong thing
doing the wrong thing with the wrong
person the wrong people
it takes a high level of psychological
courage
to admit when we're in the wrong thing
because it'd be easy for us to be
vulnerable and say well
i'm so stupid i can't believe i spent so
many years here
but a habit that high performers had and
really inspired me was
they quit the wrong things they quit it
fast
and it wasn't because they're quitters
it's because
they were focused on that which really
matters make a difference
like a quitter is just a quitter is
somebody who just quits because
it got difficult this is not about
difficulty it's about right and wrong
you follow they're not quitting because
there was hardship
there look high performers have you ever
heard or studied my work before
high performers honor the struggle
they're cool with struggle
they know struggle is part of the
journey to become
excellent at anything struggle is not
why they're quitting
right and progress is not necessarily
quitting too
like i've done a lot of things that
there was no initial progress towards
and everyone said brendan quit that
so you can't quit just because it's hard
and you can't quit just because
you're not getting progress there that
high performers had a different way of
thinking
about when and why to quit but it was
very
obvious i mean sitting down with them
and walking through this i even asked
many of them i said tell me about some
things you've quit in the last five
years
and they had like this laundry list of
things
and most people would identify them as a
quitter but what they were
was an ex they were think about it like
a quitter quits cause a hardship
but there's another critter who quits
because of priority
because of distinction of what really
matters
they're willing to let go what's not
right because
they know if they don't the universe
can't maybe open up a new field
for them to play in right sometimes
if we're stuck doing the wrong thing the
universe doesn't open up some white
space for us to discover the right thing
it's how many people say you know you
know quitting that job was the best
thing i ever did they say
because their job was okay
it's not like it was bad that was my
story
if you know my story in 2006 i left a
great corporate job
i was climbing i was having great
success i was
engaged it was a great job there was
nothing
wrong with it it just wasn't the
ultimate right thing for me
and i knew it i could see some partners
lives at the company i was working at i
was like
i don't want their life i could so the
climbing up to their level wasn't my
thing
i had been there long enough i'd spent
six years and i
i got a real good perspective lots of
training met amazing people some of the
most
extraordinary people i met my entire
life great company
had a great time the company was called
accenture one of the world's largest
consulting companies
fantastic experience i didn't quit that
because it was wrong because there was
something wrong with the company or the
people
or the projects it wasn't right
enough for me
that make sense you got to find what is
right enough
for you and only you know that you can't
listen to your friends and your family
this is another thing i learned from our
the peers in high performance
they didn't make these decisions to quit
because everybody around them thought it
was a great idea
right when i told me when i told people
around me i was quitting my job
especially i had been blessed to get a
lot of mentorship and people were
putting on their partners
on a partner track i was i was climbing
they're like you're quitting
to do what i'm like write a book be like
write a book
isn't that going to take a while like i
don't know i've never done it but i feel
like i need to do that
what kind of book oh it's going to be a
fiction a parable
you know the book was called life's
golden ticket i'm like
have you ever written fiction i'm like
no well how do you know how to do that
like i don't
and you're leaving this thing that is
secure and good
for this thing that you don't know
anything about i'm like yeah
and they thought i was crazy but i tell
people i go
there is time
you got time we don't think that we have
time
because we're impatient in our world
today you got time
if you're in the wrong thing get out of
the wrong thing because you got the
you got time to find things now i know
some people say well brendan
i can't just quit because i have
financial responsibilities i go i know
i have the same thing so what i had to
do is find some of the right things and
start earning a little bit over there
i'd focus just a little bit of time over
here earn a little bit over there now i
was earning way more over here
but i'd find these things i was more
passionate about we'll talk about that
and i started earning just a little bit
and i thought you know i'm spending all
the time over here
if i spent less time here this would
rise
maybe not equal but it would rise for me
i knew my number i thought if my side
gig
can earn 15 of what i'm earning over
here i'm bailing
because i'm spending a hundred percent
of my time over here and i'm doing this
over here
between like you know 9 p.m and 3 a.m
so if 100 of the time is earning this
and only like a little bit of time is
earning this
well what if i gave this all my time now
maybe it wouldn't equal this
but would it be enough to buy a big
burrito every day
that was like my measure in san
francisco i was like can i get one of
those huge burritos
that i can kind of munch on all day
because that's all i really need
i know the health fanatics are brendan
you're so much healthier than just
eating burritos all day but you know i
was busted and that was like
i was like if i could buy a burrito
every day you know or the equivalent of
groceries for a burrito every day
then you know i'll be fine i don't need
a lot i'll strip it all down
to find what's right for me and
cut loose of what i know is good
but you know what if it's good but it's
not really good enough for your heart
and soul
then it is wrong and it is okay to say
it's wrong everyone else around you say
you can't leave a good thing and i say
you know what
i know the good thing there's nothing
wrong with the good thing
it's just not the right thing enough for
what my heart and soul was telling me
i told you this even though many people
they're like that's an advanced habit
i'm like yeah high performers
leave that which is not right enough for
them
fast and i was surprised how decisive
they were in it
i said how did you make that decision
they go i just knew
i said well did you let it play out they
said let it play it loud yeah i played
it out long enough
i said well how did you know when to
like cut ties or
or burn the boats or quit that thing to
go
just knew now i had to get a little
deeper and that's what i want to share
with you
of how did they know so here's what i
want you to do
number one identify what makes you bored
or miserable
okay what makes you bored or miserable
and then
that which makes you come alive now
here's what i found out from the high
performers
a lot of them quit that which was boring
or miserable
without knowing their passions we said
again
we all believe in our life that we we
don't start something new unless
that's my passion that's my dream i'm
supposed to do that
and it's like my whole soul that's my
different spread
no a lot of people don't know their
passions but quit that which is not
fulfilling you don't have to know
every step along the way the uncertainty
is fine
but if you are certain that this thing
that you are doing is boring
bail if you are sure it is making you
miserable
but you have tried to engage it you've
tried to change it
and you put the effort there i'm just
here to tell you what high performers
would do
is leave sooner than later i don't know
what's coming up for you i mean
some of you are like are you talking
about my marriage right now i don't know
what i'm talking about
i don't know your story but i'm here to
tell you
high performers tend to identify that
which bores them or makes them miserable
they do the effort of fully engaging it
trying to shift it
trying to change it i'm not saying that
they quit without trying
please listen i'm saying they quit
decisively
two different things they'll engage it
like i tried to make my career better
i did i tried choosing the right the
better mentors
the better projects i mean i put the
effort in trust me i really went for it
i tried but it didn't get any more
fulfilling
you know if there's something that
you're doing in your activities or
or job career relationships and i mean
you've had a good couple year run and
you worked on it
and you really gave full attention and
effort
and it didn't it didn't engage you and
you tried
and you're just like i'm bored with this
now i'm not bored with this like
social media instagram board with it
like meaning flip flip flip
because you lack commitment this is not
that's a different conversation i hope
you're hearing the distinctions here
high performers are deeply committed so
if they're deeply committed to something
i mean meaning they spent time on it
they put effort there
i mean it was real for them they engaged
it because they made that decision right
you jumped in
you chose to jump in they chose
something consciously they went in
they gave effort at it and they've
engaged with it
and now if they've engaged with it it's
just boring or it's miserable
that's when they decisively knew i'm out
and they would get out before listen to
this
it's so hard to hear they would get out
before they knew the friggin next step
they were okay with the unknown because
you know what i'm better with
i'm better with the unknown than the
known that's miserable
that's what they would say and i was
like wow
i mean that's courageous i mean that's
what we talk about in high performance
habits my book
demonstrating courage is often leaving
that which is right
because courage is ultimately stepping
into that which might bring
fear uh unknown
hardship rejection it's scary
but i'm telling you you got to be more
comfortable
moving in into uncertainty then you
allow yourself to be comfortable with
what's boring or miserable
if you want your career business to go
to the next level because you know who's
not succeeding in business
bored people you know who's not
succeeding in their careers
bored people you know who doesn't want
to go to the meeting and give they're
all
miserable people so ask yourself
is there something a project job
career relationship i don't know you
need to evaluate
and you need to be decisive today right
today
today because you already know the
answer
if anything's been rolling around in
your head you already know it my friend
and maybe you don't need a dude like me
to give you permission for it
you need to give yourself some
permission and i tell you that
only as a research base i'm not advising
you
i'm not telling you what to do as a
trainer per se on this one but i
am telling you what high performers did
now you need to say
is that relevant to me in my life
because i don't want you to do anything
irresponsible and then blame
me what i want you to do though
is what is true to you
sometimes we need that you know
maybe you need me to say it or not maybe
you knew before you even started this
video
that there were some things you need to
cut from life maybe some things are
wrong
and i'm just here to say that somehow
high performers had the courage
to do it and there were a lot of them
who said
it wasn't easy a lot of them had to let
team go
a lot of them left something they i mean
they gave their blood sweat and
tears to for years but they had to admit
wasn't the right thing
and why am i saying this to you you're
like dude i thought we were talking
about productivity
habits i'm like try to be productive
towards the wrong things
you'll wake up be unmotivated you'll be
a curmudgeon
people around you won't like you because
you'll be irritable
and then what ends up happening your
performance declines
and then suddenly it's just like you're
going through the motions
in my book high performance habits i
tell the story of a woman one of the
most influential people
uh that i've ever met has over 10 000
employees to give you an idea
um extremely extremely successful been
you know all over the media
and yet her challenge in life was she
felt like she was starting to go through
the emotions
no one wants to go through the emotions
remember we all want to feel alive
we want to feel connected we want to
feel like we're contributing
live love matter that's my thing right
we don't feel alive and
we don't feel connected we don't feel
like we're contributing if it's in a
miserable place
your family doesn't need to see you as
an example of misery
your team doesn't need to see a
disengaged
person i mean would you agree i mean
right now
i mean it's so obvious we have so many
people in the world right now who are
half
interested you know lovers half-hearted
leaders
you know half engaged employees
and it's ruining it for everybody else
it draws down gdp
it that gross domestic product it makes
the work environment suck it makes the
home life suck
so you got to find out what's boring or
miserable
and be on the lookout for that which
makes you come alive
notice i really hammered this and then i
mentioned this one
and that which makes you come alive
because a lot of people didn't know that
which made him come alive until they
experimented
right if it's wrong boring and miserable
you make the conscious decision
i'm going to try some new things you
choose when to leave but you try some
new things
and see which one makes you come alive
you got to experiment
you got to try a lot of different things
i tried so many things
when i left that company i mean true i
mean i literally tried
like hundreds of different things over
the years
and the ones that i really connected
with i knew
i felt fulfilled you know when it's not
right
it's just hard to admit it sometimes
it's true
you know what's right just hard to admit
it sometimes
high performers are admitting it and by
listen
the productivity gains and i listed
advance because it takes courage
the productivity gains come in their
life because they've cleared the decks
you've heard the phrase spring cleaning
if you don't spring clean your life
once in a while you know there ends up
being all this clutter
and all this clutter it's harder to move
around the house it's harder to manage
things and so sometimes the greatest
productivity gains in our life
comes when we open up the white space in
our life
we simplify we identify that which
is making us more come to life because
if it's something that makes us come
more to life
we focus a little bit more on it we're
more motivated in the morning so our
productivity gains
grow your productivity lags when you're
bored or miserable
i know you get it but i'm telling you
every one
of the top 15 of high performers
remember high performers tended to be
the top 15 percent in in the general
public anyway
meaning they were the 15 percent in
whatever field or discipline we were
studying they were the top 15 percent
athletes who were studying athletes they
were top 15
earners if we were studying sales people
they were top 15
um in terms of their 360 peer reviews
whatever we were studying whatever area
the top 15 of that top 15 percent
everyone i interviewed i interviewed
over 30 of them
in depth remember this is the top 15
of the top 15 every one of them talked
about this and i was like
dang you guys are gutsy
that's gonna be hard to teach people
they're gonna they're gonna blame me for
wrecked marriages and all these sorts of
things
but it was definitely a pattern number
two
think legacy one of the easiest ways to
know if it's not right for you is
you know when you turn 50 60 or 70 and
you're looking back
are you proud of the output
that you generated in that space right
earlier today i talked to you about
prolific quality output
in your primary field of interest and
spending 60 percent of your week
there okay if that's what you did
you said this is my area focus and
you're creating in that space
and you're putting 60 of your work
effort towards that well when you're 70
80 or 90 years old do you look back and
go
proud of that feel good about those
contributions
i find fulfillment there and
it left a good message in the world or
left a good mark
in the world or it made a difference
with those
around there like if you're there at the
end of your life and you're evaluating
what you've done
are you proud of that thing and a lot of
people are scared of that
you know they really are and so they
they don't want to face it and so they
don't quit and i'll give you an example
uh
from my very young uh very young in my
life
um matter of fact i was what in middle
school i was high school
i was in high school and um i had a job
and uh it was basically as a janitor
in this big trucking company and i was
pushing the broom
that was my job i basically came in
pushed the broom across the shop floor
which was
i don't know 10 000 square feet maybe um
and uh you know the trucks were in there
all the time and there's oil and stuff
and mud all over the place and
i had to you know put the stuff on the
oil to soak it up and i had to sweep the
whole thing with one sweeper that was
this big
i still don't know why i didn't like how
anyway
a little crappy sweeper and i was just i
mean it was just
exhausting work and i remember
one day i'm sweeping and i'm thinking am
i going to be proud of
this work 10 years from now i have no
idea why i thought that i'm a kid in
high school
and i was like i'm going to be proud
that i
had the hard job and that i did it well
but if i'm here a year from now i will
not be proud
you follow saying it doesn't mean that
you can't be prideful of the activity or
the hard work
recognize that but as a legacy if you
stay there too long
there's a difference you follow i knew
if i was still
pushing broom a year later that i wasn't
activating my
personal passion or activating my
personal potential and remember i didn't
know the right thing
i just knew that wasn't my legacy and by
the way i don't bemoan that because i've
worked with so many extraordinary
extraordinary
people in maintenance and engineering
and janitorial work
if that's their thing that's their thing
i mean if you read my book life's golden
ticket the hero
is essentially the groundskeeper right
so i i i connect with that work if it's
done in a certain way but for me that
wasn't going to be my legacy
so maybe you say if what you're doing
now
in three years are are you proud that
you're still doing that thing in three
years
because that thing is changing people's
lives
making your mark doing something
fulfilling
my job here is just to cue you as a high
performance coach that's what i'm always
trying to do
i'm trying to cue you to find your own
answers but this is kind of how they
told me they thought through and
evaluated
those quitting things that were wrong
number two or number three
is so hard release those who are not
ready
um most of the highest earning uh guys
and gals i spoke to
who had teams you know had employees or
significant numbers of contractors or
they had a team of people who helped
them do what they do and they were the
highest earning most of them had
significant teams and employees they
would talk all the time about
the challenge of scaling and as they
went to scale
to the new thing that
you know the thing they were doing
wasn't necessarily wrong and the team
wasn't necessarily wrong
but there were some people who weren't
ready for scale and they had to
let that person go everybody had
everybody had that story
um i've had that in my own career over
the years of my own brand in business
i've learned that too
there's just some people who they're
right there at the right time
but then as you scale and times change
their needs change they're not right
anymore
and what they did is they released those
people
they laid them off they fired them they
left them
and it does not mean it was easy process
this is why i wanted to start with this
one for you
brandon this is heavy stuff dude i know
but i would say this was the habit i
told you
it's advanced it's advanced because the
courage is there
what do you need to quit who do you need
to quit who do you need to let go on
who isn't right maybe they were right in
your life years ago
they're just not right now and that's
okay it doesn't mean they're wrong
i think we're all so scared to hurt
people's feelings
that we put up with drudgery
for years for for what
for the sake of being in a drudgery
relationship
or being a drudgery project the world
needs to see us come alive
not miserable and you need to find your
freedom at this stage of your life
whatever that means
it doesn't mean just quitting on people
irresponsibly
what it does mean is being judicious
about thinking through where you are at
this stage of your life
and what really is right for the next
stage because sometimes it's very
different
what's right for you the next stage look
you're also gonna have to let go of some
of your skills
there's so many things i am good at that
i don't do anymore
right think about that is it true
there's some skills that you are so good
at
that you don't really do anymore at this
stage of your life it's just not right
i don't push a broom anymore i'm i am a
hell of a broom pusher i'm amazing i
mean i can brew
look i am unbelievable at cleaning
things
i can be obsessive to the nth degree
but i don't it's just not relevant in my
life anymore
there was a time that that really
mattered for me right
it doesn't matter for me anymore i had
to let that skill go
to focus on the next level of
contribution it makes sense there's a
lot of thing oh my gosh
i am so good at design i mean if you
ever
well okay i think i'm good at design but
if you ever got something in the mail
from me
i designed that if you've seen the last
uh all of my books
i designed those book covers if you've
seen most of my websites over the last
decade outside of this last year or two
i did those i know a lot of those were
janky i mean i love to design things i
love to make big brochures that are
fancy and amazing
but me spending time there doesn't make
sense for where i'm going
you follow like i really love to dork
out about audio and video
doesn't make sense for me to spend a
tremendous amount of time there because
there are other people who are better at
that
who can contribute there even more
magically and way better than i ever
could
even though i dork out about it i gotta
let's go sometimes
you got to let go of some of your
passions
for the next stage of your life too if
you can accept that
i bet you can accept sometimes you gotta
let go of some of the people
to go to the next level too those people
especially for high performers
they're the naysayers the doubters
the haters the negative energy people
it's not saying they're good people or
bad people it's just saying
their energy is not readying you for
your next level
of life your next level of learning
growth
contribution be aware of that just be
aware
that's my job in helping you do this i
know this is a difficult one and a heavy
one for
a lot of you other you're like i don't
know what he's talking about
everything's great brandon
hey wherever you're at awesome that is
habit number one
quit the wrong thing sooner than later
because that's what high performers are
they're decisive about this i know i'm
going on and on and on this
but i'm trying to get this into your
body and into your mind and into your
life
because this is a habit remember they
didn't do it one time
they told me like 10 15 things it was
like whoa
this is a thing okay and it made me
look at my own life and go i gotta do
some of that too man that's hard
bold courageous work that's how you hit
high performance okay i got the question
what do you do if you're feeling
angry like when it just it just bubbles
up and you want to burst on somebody
i get this question all the time from
you all here on facebook and
as well as on youtube and all over the
web so what do you do with that
right now a lot of people are feeling
very
very angry and have you noticed that a
lot of people recently
kind of feel like personally offended
about everything
you know everybody right now in the
culture it feels like
is getting so offended by the smallest
little things
one misstatement over here and the world
bursts at them
and bullies them and i bet you've been
victim to that too
that you've felt in the culture that
there's a little more anger
right now maybe it's the political
process i don't know this is not a
political statement
it's an answer to the question brendan
what do i do if i feel so angry inside
i'm about to wreck stuff
um this is your tutorial on that
four big ideas for you when you're
feeling angry
number one wait you know before you say
that mean comment before you write that
mean just reactive post before you freak
out on somebody or break
something always soon as you feel angry
make your mind go wait you have to train
yourself on that see there's this old
thing in psychology you know it
stimulus and response and the people who
keep struggling
over and over and over in their
relationships
in their careers on any path to
achieving anything significant
who keep struggling do so because they
keep
living from a place that is too
impulsive
they are impulsively reacting to the
world they're always reacting
and they're justifying the reacting well
you made me do this you made me feel
that
no one makes you feel anything without
your permission
eleanor roosevelt taught us that didn't
she that it is on
us to control our internal
representations
internal thoughts internal feelings
the world is not responsible for that we
are responsible
for self and our reactions to the world
and i know you already know that
so you must develop a great capacity in
life to go
wait whenever you have that feeling that
comes up to anger
because most time anger is coming from
an impulsive part of ourselves
that is reacting to a hurt that probably
isn't really there
that is coming from a place that is
worry there isn't nothing something we
need to worry about
it's usually what i call the drama mind
you know what i'm talking about
like it's like ah because most anger is
just poor management
of the mind the mind comes up and this
ego
child comes out and says how dare you
and you scream at somebody
when they didn't do anything in the big
plan of things that was
that big of a deal you took something
personal and they weren't even talking
about you
you took something personal and they
weren't even thinking about you
you took something personal and it
didn't even apply
it wasn't even stated in a way and so
often
most of our anger we didn't even hear it
right
or we were hearing it for us and it had
nothing to do with us
or it came from that place where someone
was saying something
and it sparked an old reaction inside of
us
that just welled up or burst like an old
pipe
from some old stories most anger
isn't happening in the actual context of
what's going on
it's an old story coming up an old hurt
an old wound an old concern
am i respected enough am i cared for
enough
how dare they all these things
are the child mind they're the ego mind
i just call it the drama
mind the thing that wants to make
something a bigger problem than it
really is
because you have no perspective on life
but i bet as you've traveled or
you've experienced more in life you've
realized a lot of people have it very
difficult
out in life you've realized there's a
lot of poverty
you've realized there's a lot of
struggle you realize there's a lot of
hurt and pain
and hopefully that gives you some
perspective to say geez
somebody cutting me off isn't such a big
deal anymore
because here's the reality especially
if you keep getting angry about the same
thing over and over and over again
you are a victim of the drama mind and
that victim
is you you have the ability to turn that
off and the way you do it is
wait you enlarge the gap of time between
stimulus
and response that's where all
self-mastery comes from
enlarging the time between stimulus
and response so now it's not the drama
mind it's not the impulsive mind
it's the intentional mind it's the mind
that says
how would i deal with this if i was
centered
how would i deal with this if i was an
adult how would i deal with this if i
could be proud about myself
later on your job wait
and enlarge that gap so that you can
listen
so that you can ask questions so that
you can still engage with
it but not fight with it so that you can
understand what's really happening
and that you can get composure because
you'll find personal
strength and pride in finding composure
because if you keep losing your
composure over and over and over to the
same things
you're a child and i don't mean that in
a derogatory
phrase i mean that is you're still
operating like a child from a reactive
place let me give you an example
i know a lot of people who on their
morning commute
every morning on their commute they get
angry every single morning
the same thing happens every morning
somebody cuts them off and they go into
a rage about it every
day and i go if you know something's
gonna happen
and it's gonna lead the same negative
emotional reality every time
then you're just a pavlovian dog who
hasn't trained yourself
if you don't learn to anticipate it
and adjust your response to it you're
still the child
but hey listen truthfully if you're
still getting upset about the same thing
over and over and over again
it's time to step back as an adult and
say wait
is there a better way to deal with this
for my health
for myself for other people enlarge the
gap between stimulus
and response and now you have intention
now you have more personal power
so whatever time that feeling of anger
comes up
wait second w
wonder ask yourself where is this coming
from
this anger as you're waiting to react
go where is it coming from what am i
really upset about here
and it'll give you perspective when
someone cuts you off
and you feel angry wonder is this really
about me
maybe that person didn't even see me
maybe that person just yeah maybe
they are are they really rude are they
really terrible people because they cut
you off
maybe they need to get home because
their child is sick
maybe there are an emergency they need
to get home faster than you
maybe they truly didn't see you and
maybe it doesn't even matter
because it's always going to happen and
those things are always going to happen
we must wonder
why is that still triggering me what is
it about that
i think it's important to learn to have
more of a buddhist or
stoic philosophy about our emotions in
life
to be able a little dispassionate from
this to step back to be the observer to
step back and wonder
why am i acting so angry right now
what is it about myself where do i feel
like i'm not being valued or respected
and why do i have to be so valued and
respected why don't i let go of all that
because you find extraordinary power
in uncoupling unconnecting yourself
from the emotions that get you so razzed
up to let yourself go go
oh i see myself getting upset here i
wonder why
and then let it go i wonder what's got
me here oh that's it because once you
know what upsets you
and you're in control of that now you
understand
with understanding comes a great level
of emotional
power the third one this is my favorite
technique my favorite tool
if you're like dude i can't wait and i
don't know why i'm at it i'm just mad
then insert this question as soon as
that anger comes up ask a simple
question
how would my highest self respond
have the expectation in your life from
now on that you're going to respond to
situations
with grace with ease with confidence
with a sense of peace and centeredness
that was one of the changing days in my
life i remember
i used to be offended a lot when i was a
19 year old kid you know this is 20
years ago but
i remember i'd gotten i'd been through a
breakup with somebody i really loved
and it was an awful breakup and i felt
terrible and hated myself hated that
person
and i had all this anger and hatred for
months and months and months
it ultimately led to so much anger that
it
drew me to suicide and
a lot of people don't know that and it
was a very difficult time
of my life i couldn't make it through
the day
and i planned on taking my life and the
anger
it just it was sizzling in me
and i felt like it had me and i felt
so justified in my anger don't we always
feel so justified
and then one day i thought i know i'm
i'm a weak man i know that i have sinned
i know that i am not perfect but
if i could have a person
who's so much wiser than me if i could
look out into the future
and my highest best strongest happiest
boldest self
could step into the situation how would
my better self advise me now
and you'll always find that your better
self will say
calm down it's not that big of a deal
in the bigger picture you're stronger
than you know
believe in your ability to figure this
out
take a breath take a couple breaths
know that you could make the situation
awful and make yourself
feel bad but that's your choice
your highest self would tell you you
know what
handle this well so you can respect
yourself later
your best self would say handle yourself
well now
just to prove that you can your best
self would say
you know what if you handle yourself now
you'll have
fewer regrets later your best self would
say you know what instead of being angry
try to be compassionate because from
compassion
and love comes a greater power to
influence than you'll ever have as an
angry little child
your older self they'd tell you they'd
learn you
they'd give you the messages that you
needed to hurt what would you do
as your highest self i like my trigger
for myself is when i feel those negative
emotions i ask a very specific question
my question is
if i was acting as my highest self now
what would be my next
right action of integrity coming from a
place
where i want to be happy as a human
being
how would i reply to this and that
changes the game
the questions we ask ourselves in
moments of conflict
dictate the answers and the way in which
we behave
and so i say to you take a beat ask the
questions
wonder why you're so upset and let it go
ask what would my highest self do in the
situation
and the last idea just another w
well-being well being
ask yourself what would my reply be in
this case
that would help me develop well-being of
mind
of heart and how could i respond in this
way
that would help somebody else with their
well-being that would give them
a little more perspective a little bit
more wisdom not as
the holier than thou i'm so better than
you oh i hate you and you scream at the
person
but instead how could i explain myself
so i feel good about myself and i've
conveyed what i need to convey
but i also did it in a way that they
became better because what if you went
from the angry
responsive reactive impulsive child
into the adult that inspired the world
with how you behaved even when you had
the right to be angry
what if even though nelson mandela had
all the reason in the world
to walk out of his jail cell and be
angry and he
what if he had done it we wouldn't have
had the obliteration of apartheid we
would not have a nobel prize winning
person we wouldn't if i had somebody who
millions and millions and millions of
people
went to the streets in peace marches to
support
when he passed away the world celebrated
looked at as not just an inspiration but
an icon
you look at the people who have all the
reason in the world to be angry
a martin luther king a mother teresa
people who have been
vilified taught bad but they held their
center
they still thought in terms of not angry
responsiveness
but service to the world they knew that
their role was to be
a role model maybe next time you have
all the
reason in the world to be angry you
don't justify it and you say i'm gonna
take a higher ground
i'm gonna use this incident this moment
this time
to develop some personal strength i'm
gonna use this moment this time
this context to inspire i'm going to use
this moment this time
to be the rational mind here to be the
mind
that will help that will serve that will
demonstrate patience because patience is
a virtue
i will use this time this moment
to demonstrate that i am a good person
if you can do that
more often than you have in the past
you will start to feel stronger and you
will start to feel what we call
the charge like i believe that destiny
is not so unknowable
you know so many people wonder how their
life is going to turn out where am i
going to end up
what will the my ultimate legacy and
contribution be
in the world will i live a good life
will i have success will
i make it will i have the wealth and
influence that i need to achieve the
things i want to achieve and
contribute the things that i want to
contribute but often when people
ask those things and they say those
things they see them from such a
almost like a disempowering place as if
they believe they have no
hand in their destiny as if it's all
driven by just
fate as if it's all driven just by luck
or blessings and
the truth is it is driven by some of
those things but i think that
most of our life and where we're going
to end up in our lives really comes down
to three simple things
and that first thing is deciding who are
we going to be
you know we shouldn't hope to end up one
day a magnificent
strong beautiful capable kind loving
person
we should start living like that today
hopefully so that
we become that that who we become is not
a
an accident but hopefully a purposeful
intent
that our days and how we approach our
days
are literally driven by the intention of
who we're going to bring
that we bring our character into each of
the circumstances of our lives
and by doing that maybe we can't always
direct every circumstance of our life we
can't control everything but we can
certainly control our responses to them
we can certainly
dictate who we're going to be in those
circumstances and that helps us achieve
our ultimate destiny that we desire
not one that just lands on us i think
the other thing that really
comes to people's into their power is
when they really discover that you know
each of our days is something that we
can
also design not just design who we're
going to be how are you going to design
your day
what's this day going to be about what's
going to get your attention what's going
to get your focus
and what should not be getting your
focus is just your inbox or
just what i call browser blackout
clicking around on all these blue links
or images
or swiping here and swiping there and
then losing four or five hours
of your day because what ends up
happening for so many people is
they lose two or three hours to
distraction each day maybe four hours of
distraction of television a day
and over the course their lives now a
decade is gone
of opportunity a decade of op missed
opportunities to connect with your
family to
achieve your dreams to work a little
harder to contribute that thing you
always contribute to learn
that skill that you wanted to learn like
we have to
decide on our days we have to design
them
we have to wake up and decide what this
day is going to be about
what's going to get done what's going to
deserve our focus who will we reach
out to instead of just responding to
everybody else's needs
we did this thing at high performance
academy the simple study and we found
that
if you check your email in the first
hour of your day
unless you're in customer service or
your job is doing that every single
day if you check your email in the first
hour of the day you lose 30
productivity over the course of the week
why because you're opening your day and
you're opening your inbox and jumping
into other people's agendas
the inbox is nothing but a convenient
organizing system for other people's
agendas if you wake up in reaction to
the world you're always going to be in
reaction you won't design your destiny
you'll just have one
and you may or may not like it so first
we have to desi
decide who we're going to be second we
have to design our days
and third we have to deal with fate you
know
fate is the real thing things happen to
us each day and maybe they were destined
maybe you believe that or you don't but
maybe the reality is each day is always
going to bring the same
sort of three recurring characters and
once you realize that then life isn't so
mysterious
it's just about how you respond to those
same
three recurring characters because they
show up in cycles
and they show up throughout your life no
matter what every single day i mean fate
only bears three essential things on the
shoulders right
every single day what's going to show up
for us well we know that at some point
fate is going to introduce us to
struggle and suffering
things aren't going to go well we're
going to have a bad day
we're going to have to go through things
and times in our lives where we feel
like we really are in a lot of pain and
we have to suffer for a period of time
we might not know how long that period
of time is going to be but we do know
that fate will introduce us to her
so if that's real then maybe we should
decide as we become more mature beings
as
we start trying to live a more
consciously designed life that we say
you know what
struggle is going to happen suffering is
going to come
when it comes who am i going to be
and how in those times will i find and
decide on what my day will be
because those things happen to all of us
you know i remember
after a recent accident where i had a
brain injury i
wrecked an atv while i was racing with
some friends on atvs and
i ended up with a brain injury and it
was brutal and it was a period of time
in my life where i felt like i was
suffering every day
physically i'd broken my wrists and
broken up my ribs and
threw out my hip and had whiplash and
had a lasting concussion
that led to the need to get some neat
some some help
by a neuroscientist to help kind of
recover
and in that process of healing and
therapy it was difficult
so i had to be more disciplined about
who i was going to be
and what my day was going to be about
what emotions i was going to bring to
life what habits i was going
to form where i was going to allow
myself to go mentally
could i go into that deep sort of that
that deep chasm of negativity
and drown in my own sort of pools of
pessimism or
could i find something more to attach to
could i find something to be
enthusiastic about in the future
even if today sucked that's our great
challenge in dealing with the fate
that brings us sometimes struggle and
suffering but fate
also brings us gifts and blessings
and we ought to be really aware of those
and i think
incredibly grateful and thankful for
them that i think that the more that we
appreciate
and and experience the gifts and
blessings of life with real
joy and deep gratitude
i think fate says hey this this this gal
over here this guy over here
they like this let's give a little more
you know it's recognition by the
universe or god or the creator or
the cosmos whatever you vibe to that
says yeah
this person appreciates what they've
been given and even if you don't believe
in all that divine
stuff well then hey just maybe just
maybe
you can take a look around and think
about who should i appreciate today
who deserves a little more gratitude for
the the blessings and the gifts that
they've
brought into my life maybe you ought to
just take stock
and realize how lucky you are to be
breathing to be alive to
to have the gifts the opportunities the
joys the strengths
that you have and maybe you can
encourage the people around you to have
that same
sense because i think we also get to
decide
how we will deal with fate when it
brings us the good things
and i think the last characters that
fate continually brings into our life
is love and loss you know we get to
we get to meet new people there's seven
billion people on the planet we get to
connect with people
we ought to compliment them we ought to
feel connected with them we ought to
think about the people who we love reach
out to them send them a letter
send them an email call them thank them
put our arm on the shoulder
appreciate them i think that the gift
that fate keeps bringing back to us
of love as this recurring character in
our life is one of our greatest
gifts and blessings if i can blur those
lines a little bit
you know that there's somebody in your
life who's loved you
and there are people in your life who
you love how attentive
and appreciative are you to those people
that's designing your destiny too
because at the end you're going to
wonder whether or not you're really
loved
so why not live your life each day by
conscious design
so at the end your movie looks like a
love epic
and then there's also the reality of
loss that
you know several years ago i had to deal
with that i lost my dad
and my dad was one of my great heroes
and great friends
and i remember as i'm struggling through
that
my whole family is struggling through
that from his diagnosis
of acute myeloid leukemia to his death
was 59 days it was very we lost him very
quickly had no idea it was coming
and when that happens you have to ask
how are you going to deal with it
how are you going to deal with loss
we're all going to lose something that
we love we're all going to lose somebody
that we love
it's going to happen it's just going to
happen none of us escape that fate
so when it happens what will you bring
to it where will your mind be what will
you focus on
i focused on appreciation sheer
joy and gratitude in my memory of my
ability to carry on my father's torch of
my ability to carry on his message you
know he was always saying the same
things to us
so i'd sit down and write him out and i
think about what he said you know he's
always saying
be yourself do your best
be a good citizen be kind to others and
respect them
follow your dreams you know all these
things he was always saying to us
i just write them down i can just
usually recollect them and i choose to
focus on his message
who he was as a man what he brought into
my life what i might be
able to bring into my family's life by
honoring him by
by modeling him and i think that that's
the way you have to deal with things you
know we're all going to lose someone so
just carry them on so it doesn't feel
like such a loss
carry on their message carry on their
spirit carry on their teachings
carry on those things that made them
alive and vibrant
and joyous and loving and then
it's not such a hard fate to suffer
through it's not such a
hard reality it will always suck i will
always miss my dad
that i wish he was here but he is here
and that's what brings me joy those are
the things that i think that help us
decide our destiny
what are you going to be about today
what's your day today
going to be designed as what are you
going to focus on
today tomorrow the next time that fate
turns its head either positively or
negatively towards you what are you
going to do with
it that's the question of the
consciously designed life
how do we deal with this global pandemic
in a way
that is helpful to us and not hurtful
to us that has been what i've been
talking about in this series with you
and i thank all of you for all the love
the dms
the comments the support the the
cheering on that i'm doing this series
for you
every single day because i just want to
be here for you cheer you on
let you know that you know right now
it's difficult it's hard but the good
thing is
listen we're all experiencing it
together and usually where we're
so divisive we can choose this moment to
not only come together
but to summon the greatest
aspects of our own humanity right now
because if we won't summon the best of
who we are now in the face of difficulty
when are we going to do it we won't have
the same necessity when everything's
you know peaches and roses i don't even
know if that's a saying but you know
what i'm saying
i think this is an opportunity for us
to really demonstrate the values we
espouse
the values we believe about kindness the
values we believe about leadership the
values we believe about
personal development self-mastery
showing up and i know
that's difficult i don't pretend that
this is such a
easy time i just pretend that
it's a necessary time it is
here we have to accept
we have to allow we have to experience
we have to not deny or avoid our
feelings we have to not ask other people
deny or avoid their own
however episode four here
of striving in chaos on the brennan show
podcast i thought i would take on
something that's
not probably going to be super popular
y'all and i'm sorry i have to tell you
that and i
i recognize that so allow me
my time to make a little bit of case
with you that might actually serve you
because here's what i keep hearing what
i'm going to call this
episode i'm going to call this episode
this crisis
is different this
crisis is different how many of you
you know thumbs up double hands up have
heard this statement
and maybe the statement has been used to
justify
some good behavior and some mad
behavior this crisis is different
it's different and you know what it is
it is a very serious time we must take
this pandemic this is this is the
greatest pandemic
of our modern era it's unprecedented it
is scary
it is something that we can all you know
really really
overreact to and it's something that
although we also have to take
precautions to
but please note what is happening now
as we edge longer into this crisis
people start taking this crisis is
different which
is a good thing at the beginning for for
us to recognize as humans
when you notice something is different
our brain is actually built for that
right our literally our neurobiological
feedback
sparks right on when something is
different we're supposed to notice
things
as we talk about neuroscience that are
novel right
novelty really lights up the brain
novelty tells the brain
say hey pay attention to this um let's
let's summon our resources and see
how we need to respond to this that's
not what we expected
noticing novelty is what allows us to
protect ourselves noticing what is
different
is something that really is an
empowering thing
and being aware of something out of
place that helps us stay
safe so when we say this crisis is
different
at first hey listen that was a good
thing that was saying hey all this is
different
this is new be careful take these
actions
let's do these precautions and it was a
wonderful thing
and still some people say hey good
leaders out there who i love you and i
appreciate each of you when you say
this crisis is different some of you are
using that to say hey you know what
wow this is a moment right now this is
an opportunity for
me to show the best of who i am for me
to care for my family differently for me
to show my
family and my friends what i'm all about
really right now because i will say it
throughout
this series on the brennan show podcast
it's a must that we adopt a role model
mindset
the kids are watching your community's
watching your future self is going to
look back and watch and ask how you
dealt with it
so adopting that role model mindset is
so important
that that role model mindset summons you
to be better
than you feel sometimes to be better
than you when you are
and i think that's really important yes
you can be allowing yes you can rest yes
you can recover i've talked about that
throughout this series and i hope you've
tuned in
however you know while some leaders are
taking that call of
this crisis is different and they are
showing up for it
other people i'm here to tell you are
not
maybe behaving so um justly
and so we are seeing people use this
crisis is different
and the weight of it to maybe enact some
things that aren't going to serve them
through this and aren't going to serve
their community so i'm going to have a
list of things here that are not
going to help because so much of what
i've been doing on the podcast if you've
been listening to brandon show podcast
is is cheering encouraging demanding
like just really like being that voice
of positivity and empowerment for people
but part of that right now is i think to
recognize that listen
just because we're in a pandemic not
everything gets a pass
can i get an amen on a weekday right not
every behavior gets a pass
you don't get to just because there's
this pan
there's a situation where you're in your
house
away from other people or with the
family
or with the kids and there's new demands
on you
listen new demands doesn't necessarily
justify
bad behavior right we know
we still know throughout the march of
time in psychology sociology physiology
we know in uh every area of human study
from philosophy
all the way to politics straight down to
our daily behavior
we know what makes people happy it's not
a mystery
and some people are using this crisis as
different
to summon the best of themselves to
recognize the opportunity to lead
to take some time to reflect to redefine
to recalibrate to rest to recover
to organize the house some people are
using this time for
real self-introspection real rest
or real opportunities to lead and serve
and be role models some
people are using this fact that this
crisis is different in positive ways
however i bet some of you have also
noticed something that i want to talk
about because i'm your coach
i got to keep people accountable i got
to be real and what is happening also
some people are saying this crisis is
different and they're using that to
justify
bad behavior justify
hate justify complaint justify
their bad attitude that's carrying on
weeks and months
justify lying cheating stealing
enacting irresponsible behaviors for
themselves and their families
demanding things from other people in
entitled and rude ways
and i know this is not popular and i
know listen i'll probably get skewered
for even bringing this up
how dare somebody say that we should
practice good values
throughout such difficult times what a
jerk brendan is he you know he lacks all
empathy he doesn't
understand that people of course are
gonna burst out in anger and
upset and that they're gonna you know do
these things because you know the stress
and the overwhelms
getting to people and you have to allow
them to be you know rude and who they
are
and i'm like ah maybe maybe
is stress real yeah is overwhelmed yes
is threat to our lives scary yes but
your life
if you're at home right now is
on average by the vast majority average
i don't know
seven billion people is not any more
threatened
necessarily than it was last year
meaning
last year you might have been out
driving your car
last year you might have got the flu
last year you might have had the same
incidence of heart disease diabetes last
year you might not have been safe too
and i'm not saying this is not different
it is different and it is scary but
listen
stress overwhelm and all the things we
are facing now we have also faced before
right we have also faced before and we
faced bigger things
before it is not minimizing these things
what he's doing is contextualizing the
fact that
stress and overwhelm is not new to your
life yes these are new stressors
yes this is a new way to be overwhelmed
yes it's collectively heavy
yes it is different but it does not
justify you
spreading hate it does not justify you
complaining
24 7. it does not justify you saying
these people are horrible and terrible
and
it doesn't justify us becoming more
divisive
does this pandemic justify anyone to
become more decisive
divisive i'm sorry it's like does this
give us a reason
to hate groups more i don't think so
i think this is a cause to maybe
recognize we're collectively in
something together
does this justify people coming at
you being rude trying to take what's not
theirs
acting from scarcity and anger and hurt
to others i don't think so
here's my list right now that i'm seeing
number one people are using
using and i mean they're literally using
it they're not conscious of it yet
but someday it will be revealed to them
as they gain higher consciousness and
awareness
that they're using this this situation
that this is different
as a reason to demonstrate bad attitude
well you i can be rude i can i can have
a crappy outlook
i deserve to have a crappy outlook this
is terrible this is terrible
oh that's that's what they're doing
they're like i
my attitude that's negative is deserved
because these such
hey your attitude could have been
deserved when you couldn't pay the bills
too
your attitude could have been your bad
attitude could have been deserved when
someone treated you wrong
we've always had to choose it and i keep
talking about this over and over
that you know viktor frankl's book man
search for meaning where he talked about
the last of the human freedoms
they can take away everything from you
but they cannot take away one's ability
to choose one's own attitude
so you can't use the crisis to choose a
negative attitude and justify it
attitude the second thing on people
seeing people justify
is rudeness and
complaint and hate i'm gonna bucket them
all together because i really feel like
it's like oh
i can be rude right now i can be
demanding right now of other people they
should give me this
because it's hard on me i was like whoa
hey listen it's hard on all of us
you you don't get special treatment
just because the context changed there's
a lot of people demanding
things that are like not real not fair
not good right now and you're like whoa
you don't get to use the context to be
demanding of other people
that doesn't make sense you can make
requests you can be kindly you can say
to your spouse hey you know what i i
need a little bit more help right now
this is really hard i'm a little
stressed and overwhelmed and sometimes i
just my day kind of i'm losing a couple
days
of here uh you can lean on your teams
more you can lean on friends
more but to demand it
just because the context right how dare
you not give me x there's a pandemic
going on
it's like whoa hold on there i've seen
people another thing
lying and cheating and remember you're
talking to brainerd start here who never
talks about
the real negative aspects of our lives
because i'm more of the
re like i'm more the positive psychology
type of guy who's saying hey let's focus
on our strengths let's build those
but i see people lying and cheating and
demanding right now
in ways that aren't right they're going
to companies and they're saying
hey i bought something two years from
you two years ago from you but i need
money now so give it to me and if you
don't i'm gonna trash you online as
being
insensitive guys i've really had that
happen to me i
literally we've had clients people from
years ago
say hey i this is hard times i want
money back from that i'm like
do you go to amazon and ask for money
back from something three years ago
because it's hard right now
like we can't use the context just to
get whatever we want or demand whatever
we want and threaten other people when
we don't get what we want
yes it's hard times but it doesn't
justify irresponsible behavior or poor
ethical behavior
like right if we give up on our ethics
now
right versus wrong truth
if we forget justice if we forget mercy
if we forget kindness now
and we become demanding entitled
bratty rude hate-filled or threatening
to people
what have we achieved when this moment
in time will remember
you know all my friends right now are
often reminding of
us of all the neuroscience right in that
in our memories or our times in our
lives
that there are these you know peak
moments these big dramatic moments like
this is a dramatic moment
in history right now right that we're
going to be able to summon
our recollection of how we
acted then so easily one year
two year five year ten years just like
you remember when 9 11 happened
right and where you were and how you
behaved people and how you treated
people and remember the country coming
together
well guess what we're having the same
thing a year two three four years from
now we're gonna look back
and either we're gonna go i was proud of
myself or ooh
i you know i wasn't please don't let
this
this is different this crisis is
different context allow you to be
irresponsible rude uh you know
demanding of other people because guess
what they're going through hardship just
like you
they're going through hardship which is
like what if they pushed their emotions
on you right now
what if they demanded things from you
that they didn't deserve or they didn't
earn
or or or they you know i mean just think
about it for a minute
think about all the people right now who
are choosing you know what i'm not gonna
i you know what this context i can
afford to do things but i'm not gonna
pay any of my bills right now
even though they can afford to it's like
that's not gonna help our economy that's
not gonna help the world grow
by being unethical and not paying the
bills that you have when you can pay
them
now i know that folks again i know i'm
gonna get a lot of hate for this because
there are some people who truly can't
pay the bills
and that is why we are doing stimulus
packages that is why
you know uh so many business owners and
so many people are allowing or pausing
payments or doing something
like a lot of people are working really
hard but a lot of people are taking
their train wreck that was happening
months before
years before this crisis
and now they're putting that train wreck
on everybody else under the umbrella of
the crisis
and listen i know again i said i know
this is not going to be
super you know super positive
but i think that what we have to do is
hold each other to
high ethical standards always
not when it's convenient not once in a
while
i don't think that a crisis
justifies bad behavior i don't think a
crisis
should allow us to make you know
uh our issues other people issues i
don't think
that a crisis allows us to lie cheat
steal so here's what i'm encouraging my
friends you are going to so remember how
you
acted right now and if you take from
other people right now
if you lied to get yourself out of a
situation that you had already created
you're going to remember that you're
going to remember this time you go you
know what
i really did a lot of irresponsible
behavior
during that crisis and you know what
your psyche will store that up
and it will degrade degrade
your character and so what will happen
your sense of worth your sense of value
your sense of self-confidence will go
down if you justify
bad behavior and unethical behavior
based on
anything anything we all can make
excuses
to lie cheat steal be rude spread hate
but the fact that most of us don't is
why humanity is so beautiful
we can all justify it but the fact that
you my audience
doesn't do that you hold yourself to a
high standard that inspires me and it
keeps me going
so i don't want this to feel like oh
brandon went off the deep end negative
today no i'm calling a spade a spade
i'm saying let's hold ourselves to high
accountable
let's be proud of ourselves let's
instead of adopting a negative attitude
let's adopt a positive one let's be role
models
instead of you know being rude to other
people let's be extra thoughtful
with them instead of allowing all
terrible behavior let's still be leaders
let's still hold people accountable
instead of spreading hate let's really
talk about the human oneness story and
share love
instead of lying when it's convenient
because we can put it under the umbrella
of a crisis
let's realize that lying is lying
cheating is cheating
and in any given context years later
that will not only
hurt your relationships it will hurt
your psyche and your sense of
self-worth let's stop saying oh well
it's a crisis so you know
it's i'm allowed to you know do all
these bad habits i
i it's okay that you know i i'm i'm just
throwing away
uh you know my discipline i'm not gonna
take care of myself i'm gonna drown
myself in alcohol right now
that's gonna have ripple effects
oh you know what i'm gonna do i'm just
gonna i'm gonna let myself go for a
couple weeks
and that's gonna have health benefits
what do we wanna what what's the best
response right now should we
throw out all our bad behaviors become
overweight
and addicted and terrible to people
right now
or should we say you know what i better
protect my immune system
boy i i'd really better get my immune
system
teed up i i better rest i better recover
i better drink all the waters i better
you know
i better really take good care of myself
right now so that i can
pull my family through i'd better
take care of myself right now so i can
be energized before my family through
what is going to be a very long year
so i hope that this is really serving
you all because i love you
and i want to share this message with
you i'm going to be that person
throughout this i said it
day one i said listen i don't think that
i'm going to be the guy
who's just going to enable every
behavior here
i'll be empathetic but not enabling i'll
be empathetic
and empowering but as a high performance
coach the whole idea is
hold yourself to high standards and you
get to live and experience a quality of
life that most people never will
because when it gets hard they let go of
their standards
and i'm not saying everything has to be
perfect i'm not saying you have to work
equally as hard or do everything
perfectly as perfect as you used to be
able to
but i'm here to say you have standards
practice them
believe in them stick to them you know
maybe you don't get every day right
maybe one or two days slip away
but if listen we're months into this
thing if you're keeping track already
if you've let your standards go for
months re-engage
if you've been lying cheating stealing
being a positive or
being a negative attitude flip that now
because it's only going to carry on
we still got a long march ahead of us
we've got to learn
to dress that march with honor to show
up as our best selves to care for the
guy and the gal and the people around us
because it will continue
so let us be proud of ourselves please
hold yourself to high standard that is
my message right now
when it is difficult that's when you
hold yourself up to a high standard
when you have all the reason in the
world to lower yourself
you still aim high you still believe in
good things
you still live an ethical life so that
when your memory is triggered years from
now
and it will be you will look back and go
wow you know what i had all the reason
in the world
to join the liars the cheaters the
takers
the scarcity mongers the hate mongers
and you know what
i've distanced myself from them you know
what let's social distance ourself
from what we could become and instead
grow
into who we were meant to be by holding
ourselves to high
ethical standards that
is how we will strive together well and
positive
and courageously and strong in chaos
that
is your episode today of striving in
chaos
i hope you enjoyed this one listen my
friends if you didn't know i'm taking
the audio
of all these episodes i'm doing with you
that i'm calling striving on chaos
i'm putting them on the brendan show
podcast so if you're not
a subscriber to the brennan show podcast
go to the link in my bio on instagram
click that thing subscribe wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is one of the most popular series
i've ever done before because people
need
something like this to remind them of
their best humanity not just the reasons
we can all
veg out but remind ourselves of the best
of humanity too
because we can be in harmony of resting
and recovering
and we can be an activity of moving
towards our dreams improving our lives
for our families
and let us do that together let's strive
through this chaos
together let's do this now i've got a
special bonus clip from brandon burchard
and how to think
positive that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that question of the
day i
want to know what is the single greatest
piece of advice
you learned today from brendan let me
know put your answer down in the
comments below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching i want to
celebrate you because believe nation we
don't just watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you people
ask me
brendan how do i reprogram my mind and
i'm like
that's kind of creepy or you're cyborg
like why did somebody
one time like ninjutsu your brain and
hypnotizing and thinking something
horrible
like why do you need to reprogram
anything most adults don't need to
reprogram something
they just need to program it for the
first time you know it's like
there was never actually any programming
that happened anywhere there was just
all these patterns of incidences and
these circumstances that have all
coalesced into some of these automatic
thoughts
and behaviors that they aren't
necessarily being responsible for
they're
they're just they come up automatically
and they happen to them
it's not like someone said i want you to
think this i want you to think this
i want you no one ever sat you down and
probably just like
maybe it happened but for most people
that never happened
what they're really saying is brendan i
need to get a hold of my mind man
because
sometimes i just got these constant
negative recurring thoughts
that come up i can't get rid of them or
sometimes i get obsessed about this one
bad thing that happened to me
or sometimes i say you know i just can't
even control my attention dude
so what they're really struggling to do
is to master their mind in
a more sort of capable way so let's talk
about how your thoughts are generated
now some of this you might already know
if you've read my book the charge or
you've seen this my other work in high
performance academy
we talk a lot about how do you master
your psychology
i'm going to give you one simple
framework to think through
and then some tips and tools and
strategies you can immediately input
into your life
to better manage your mind the first
thing if you're having
negative recurring thoughts and feelings
that are coming up
those are really they're just they're
easy and here's what i mean by that
you know we kind of have two systems of
thought psychologists like to say now we
have
the system one theories in which the
system one is your
automatic just um unconscious
immediate thoughts and impulses that
come up from your body
that usually your brain is just saying
hey dude we've thought through this
before or hey dude we're trying to
protect you
so it's running at a very baseline easy
energetic level
your brain loves to optimize itself it
doesn't like to have to do a whole lot
of thinking
it just likes to say what do we already
know how can we apply it to this
situation
so if you had fears in the past and a
similar situation is here
your body just generates those fears and
says hey man run away again you know
if you had challenges in the past and
you want to protect yourself your brain
just says hey protect yourself right now
we're worried about this
but sometimes those are not helpful
thoughts they're automatic but they're
not
actually helpful it's just your brain
saying this is the easiest route we know
and part of becoming a more mature
conscious
enlightened person is to better take
control of our system too
which is our sort of conscious dashboard
on our mind
our ability to more directly work
control
generate and create our own thoughts
and behaviors in the moment not relying
too much
on just the things that come up for us
now of course we're always going to most
of our lives
is very system one driven very
unconscious automatic we're just going
through
the motions but the people who achieve
the peak amounts of success
the highest performers in the world have
said you know what
i need to discipline my mind to support
me even when it
comes up with an automatic immediate
thoughts i want those to be positive
and buoyant and confident and strong
something that
leads me to healthy decisions for my
life not just things that protect
me and so i think that we have to learn
how to do that one of the simple ways to
do that
is this framework to understand how
thoughts develop
into strong and automatic thoughts in
our lives i call the framework r
w i d which stands for
relative weight of importance
and duration people often who have
negative recurring thoughts and feelings
in their life
the reason those keep coming up all the
time is because they they at some point
in their life or continually
are giving those thoughts the negative
ones more attention
than necessarily any other thoughts in
other words the relative
weight that they give those thoughts is
quite high
and they give a lot of importance to
that so those those thoughts are very
important to me right now
and they're they're durationally last
over a period of time they keep thinking
about those thoughts thinking about
those things think about those thoughts
and it's all that repetition that seals
it in the back of their head
and now their head says oh this is an
easy thing i know this one and it pulls
it forward
so that simple repetition because they
made it important and they thought about
it a lot
it keeps coming up for them over and
over and over again
so there's two negative there's a good
negative thing about that a positive
thing
the negative is if you keep obsessing
about negative things
your mind will be automatically
conditioned to bring it up more and more
and more often
without your control just automatically
the positive aspect is we can use that
same skill set and that same rule to
apply
positive thoughts into our own life we
can give
positive thinking positive questions
positive
approaches to life a lot of importance
in our life
and a lot of focus and focus on them and
give a lot of duration to them over a
period of time
and they get sealed in the brain as well
and now the brain says well that's easy
automatically thinks about it so for me
personally i've done this so much in my
life that
i just have i automatically think about
the best possible outcomes in
almost everything i do i used to think
about the negative outcomes i thought
that's not supporting me
so how did i do that well leveraging
rwid
helped and let me break it down for you
a little bit about how you could do this
because
the first thing you have to do in order
to improve your mind
is take total control of your attention
and notice
where are your thoughts right now at a
very continual basis
you have to think where are my thoughts
right now are they supporting me
or are they automatically coming up
negative and self-protective in ways
that are not advancing my life
just to be aware to be conscious of
what's going on
in your body in your sense of feeling
and emotion
and the sense of the thoughts you're
actually having just start paying
attention
you know for a lot of people because
they've never done this before and it's
hard to
remind them to do it it's like simple
here's what i want you to do
just start paying attention to your
thoughts anytime
you're in line any time you're in line
from now on if you're in line at
starbucks just
say i'm in line at starbucks brandon
said think about my thoughts what are my
thoughts saying right now
just checking in you're in line in
traffic
waiting for the next car just sit and
think what are my thoughts right now
and just notice what you've been
thinking about the more
we notice what we've been thinking about
the more we can interrupt
what we've been thinking about see if we
just allow that feeling to keep coming
up and you don't pay attention to it
our life can be very frazzled and very
highly anxious
but once we say what's my mind on right
now and we
redirect it that is where personal power
comes from first awareness right and
understanding and the consciousness to
what's going on
but then the ability now to be
self-directed to choose what we want to
focus on so first we're attentive to it
and then redirect it if it's negative
it's not supporting you
redirect it how do you redirect it first
and foremost you just say what would be
the opposite of this negative thing
then you think about the positive thing
and you focus on that and you repeat it
to yourself
for many people that might include
closing their eyes
just visualizing a more positive outcome
thinking about the more positive outcome
thinking about the more positive outcome
thinking about the more positive outcome
focusing on with their eyes closed
and that visualization of a more
positive outcome
of how things could turn out well or how
good the situation
could be better or even just what are
the next steps i should take
visualizing that and assigning a high
amount of importance and duration to it
meaning
making that thing important to us by
making it how do you make something
important
you give it a sensation you feel
that thing you sense it you sense what
your next step would be
you sense how and feel if the outcome
would be better how would it feel
emotionally psychologically spiritually
for that thing to be up
allow it to have a lot of emotion to it
pay attention to
your eyes close you see that thing you
feel it you sense a different step you
know what you're going to do
you pay attention to it and you keep
focusing on that just over a period of
minutes keep focusing and keep focusing
focusing when your mind automatically
wants to go back to the easy
which might be negative you go no no i
don't want to
i don't want i'm not into easy right now
i'm into conditioning my mind
focus focus focus focus give attention
duration and sensation to it
attention duration sensation attention
duration sensation visualization
visualization
it's repetition of that positive
alternative
to a negative impulse that comes up that
gives us personal power
let me say it again it's that attention
to that positive alternative
over attention to repeating that
negative impulse or thought
that gives us personal power it's not
that we're going to someday wake up
in the perfect world in which we don't
have negative thoughts there's plenty of
times
i struggle too i come up with this i'm
thinking about a new dream a new goal
i'm gonna go interview some
you know major celebrity or we got a big
time celebrity client and i get a little
nervous
and i can start thinking about all these
negative things that could happen if i
screw up
my mind immediately interrupts that now
because my mind goes relative weight of
importance and duration brendan
you can either give this thought more
time and energy and focus
or you can just stop it and force your
brain
creatively force it to direct it to a
different
possible alternative force it literally
go oh i'm sensing this
negative thing over here is coming up
for me i'm sensing it stop
okay get to work brain what positive
thing could i create and focus on and
close your eyes
and think about it and focus on it and
focus on it and focus on and build it
out make it elaborate in your own mind
so you can visualize and see it
and feel it and focus on it focus on it
focus on focus on it
literally later on in the evening focus
on it again focus on you start
building in that capacity now if this
all
sounds way too philosophical and you're
like dude how do i land this how do i
make it happen
here's a very simple thing you can do to
reprogram your mind
create a sheet of two simple things very
simple things i want you to write
five questions down that you're going to
ask yourself
three or four times a day five questions
that are positive
for yourself that you every day you're
going to wake up in the morning you're
going to read these questions to
yourself you're going to answer them
you're going to read them you're going
to answer them every morning then at
lunch
read the questions answer them at night
read the questions
answer them these can be questions like
what can i feel incredibly grateful for
right now
how could i surprise or flirt with
somebody right now
how could i have fun right now positive
things like that right
how could i demonstrate love or
excellence right now
ask these questions in the morning ask
them the afternoon ask them at night
by asking these positive questions over
and over i mean you just do this for 30
days
you're going to recognize a total shift
in your life just
simple questions but you're giving them
weight
by focusing on them three times during
the day you're having duration by
focusing on it three times during the
day over 30 days
your mind starts to reshift its skiers
to give automatic ease
to answering those questions and living
in that mindset
versus an undirected unconscious mindset
second thing on that sheet or those
things you can do five questions first
second thing i want you to do is come up
three words that describe your ideal
self
just three words you know mine are for
example present
excited and bold so i'm gonna focus on
those questions three times a day as
well
what i do is i put them on my iphone and
they come up as an alarm
three different times during the day
just my phone buzzes and those words are
there i'm like oh right
i'm that guy i got to focus on being
that guy versus
whatever i might be in a bad mood i'm
like ah you know and completely detached
and then i look i'm like
dude no i'm an excited person break that
thought
get back into this got it this is who i
am
and now that might sound so simply
simple simply
simply it sounds so simple but guess
what people won't do the discipline
they are so frustrated with their mind
because they haven't done the conscious
discipline
to reprogram it that's the last thought
here yes we all have unconscious
thoughts
every single person of us if you don't
have a mental disorder
and then then guess what you have
extreme power in your life to overtake
it
and even those who have mental disorders
psychologists and therapists work with
them
to recondition their mind by allowing
them a different way of
attaching meaning to the past incidences
but even if they attach
meaning a different meaning to the past
the whole focus is bring them into today
and teach them to use their mind to
direct itself
into positive orientations to make
healthier
decisions to enact healthier behaviors
if you can just focus on getting more
attentive to what
you're feeling and then do these thought
exercises what questions
who do i want to be and you do that over
and over again everything changes
last thought our unconscious and our
mind
is incredibly programmed not just by
thought which is what i've been talking
about
relative weight of importance and
duration focusing our attention
on you know what questions we would ask
ourselves what positive alternatives can
we create for ourselves
what labels can we create for ourselves
to support us but our mind
also is incredibly conditioned by action
behavior you've heard the term like fake
it till you make it
i don't love that i'd rather just say
you know what just be authentic over and
over and over again
right if you take action on a consistent
basis
it teaches your mind to do that so do
things that are positive for yourself
take bolder actions teach yourself i'm
just gonna be confident you know just
for no other reason
watch my video on being confident here
on youtube i want you to really think
about this
the more that you take action the more
your brain gets automatically
conditioned to understand
that's what we do hey man that's just
what we do
we just react to bad situations like
this because that's how we've done it
you can actually condition your mind
without doing any thought
other than just behaving in a more
positive manner and suddenly you find
yourself thinking more positively
i know it sounds duplicitous but word is
blisters i think it's word sounds
good word it's like a 10 word right
there you know that's a big word for
montanan
but i really want to think about that
your actions condition
your mind as much as your recurring
thoughts condition
your mind so be a person of good
positive thinking
be a person of good positive action and
suddenly one day you'll wake up and
you're like i don't
i just feel amazing i feel extraordinary
i feel positive and that's what it feels
like
to live the charged life if you want
some more awesome motivation from wayne
dyer check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there and these top 10 principles
uh that i have put together here for
this program
you might want to jot down you might
want to go into your